Like officey and shit like that.
But the being able to be in this group
of really cool people to me is one of the
greatest benefits of being a comedian.
And one of the greatest benefits of
doing something like a podcast and these
guys at Onnit, Aubrey and all of his
employees, it's pretty laid back guy.
They're the nicest fucking people's
he you could ever want to meet.
They're approaching business.
The idea of a business where
it's something that we all enjoy,
whether it's supplements for
athletics, for, for a nootropics,
for the mind or fitness equipment.
It's all shit that we use all shit that
we feel like there's some real good
benefit to having in your life.
A Ham force protein powders
are an excellent example.
It's my favorite protein powder ever.
And I'm not saying that because
I own a piece of the company.
If I didn't have anything
to do with the company,
I will tell you that stuff is the
shit cause it's fucking delicious.
It's very low in sugar.
It has,
it has stevia in it for a sweetener,
which is a natural sweetener. So it's,
it has less than, I believe it's
maybe one gram of sugar per serving,
but it tastes delicious.
It's really easy for your body to process.
We use the highest protein content.
Hamp available is the best hamp that
you can buy and it's difficult to get.
We can only buy like
50 pounds of it a day.
They limit it because there's so much as
a massive amount of demand because hemp
cannot be grown in the
United States legally.
So we have to buy it all from Canada. You
could sell it. Yeah, you could sell it.
You can eat it. You can have
it. Cause it's not psychoactive.
But the law states that you cannot grow
hemp in the United States so you can get
it from other places. Yes,
we, we buy ours from Canada.
We have to buy it from Canada.
Man.
It's crazy. So stupid. It's so dumb. And
this is not even by the way, that's study
drug issue.
It says nothing to do with drugs folks,
because hemp is not a psychoactive plan.
It's just not.
It's only by ruthless ignorance
that this still exists.
Really ruthless.
Yeah.
Woeful cooperation with
pharmaceutical companies.
Farmers telling flowing people like,
hey, we'd like to grow the art.
They aren't, they would love to. They
pass laws. They pass laws in Vermont. Uh,
they recently passed.
Oh, by the way, today is Washington state
legal marijuana day. Congratulations.
Everybody says Washington
state, he fucking got your
shit together. Stick with it.
They're the first ones to
get your shit together.
I was in Washington state wants,
and they guy's got me high level gravity
bong that they made out of a two liter
bottle of soda.
They would put tape,
they touched off the bottom
and then we'll put tape,
like double sided tape and they'd fill
up this whole thing with six thick,
thick smoke. And they're like, hit
that. And I was like, yeah. I was like,
I couldn't take it all. They
were like, what's wrong with you?
They would take it all in one hit.
Wow.
Fuck around Seattle. You are bad
motherfuckers. Congratulations.
And Seattle's going to also try
to, um, make a growing hemp, uh,
legally goes well, yeah. Well, you
know, that's not, no, it's not.
It's all just fucking with
the federal government, man. The federal
government has these wacky positions.
I heard some of them block you up because
there's a business in locking people
up. I heard somebody put it on a ballot
like one of the states put on about like,
Hey, let's vote on the
federal, can't override our,
our state laws cause it's not
just this sort of state law,
federal law things to gay marriage. And
they eventually want to be like, Hey,
do we have any rights here?
Can we make our own shit?
Yeah, it gets a certain point in time.
It starts getting really ridiculous.
Like why are you going after these people?
It doesn't make any sense.
Like Rhode Island said that they would
use their state police to defend their
citizens with them against
up against federal troops.
And these medical marijuana weights
cause a lot of these federal troops,
by the way, they're not even
federal troops. Like they, they,
they've used mercenaries before.
Yeah. They had people that were, uh,
they were wearing black water shirts
and they were rating these. Blackwater,
blackwater is the government,
um, shirts of a, yeah,
they were wearing shirts that said they
worked for blackwater uniform and they
were brave. They were going through
these medical marijuana facilities.
What? It's crazy with machine guns on
their hips. Just some just taking the,
we'd taken the weed out. It's the only
man who are you? What are you doing?
They're like, I'm going, what are you,
just some people, cause they have a name,
the name is DEA or you know,
whatever you want to call it. CIA,
FBI. Anybody wants a string,
a couple of letters together.
Then all of a sudden who they are becomes
something different than just a person.
They're allowed to do ridiculous shit.
Like arrest you for having plants
yet you can do about it. No.
So we don't sell half a week.
We would love to sell on
it. Would love to have, um,
a whole farm and grow our own hemp.
We would love to hire
farmers to grow our shit.
We would love to keep the economy
moving in a good direction by providing
something that people want and
putting a lot of people to work.
It's a hemp is $1 billion tech
style just for clothes alone,
just for, for the nutrition that you can
get from it. It's incredibly nutritious.
All He,
I think the killer bee honey. Hey, I
like making sandwiches. Dangerous. Yeah.
I think that's why I
never understood that.
That's how they have handbags and stuff
and all the hippies get like their hemp
dresses. It all has to come from that come
from outside, from outside. All right.
I was always like, how did they not
get arrested? They're fuck heads.
We have all kinds of crazy shit at on it.
Uh,
I there's too much to name including
Buffalo Jerky and, and uh, yeah.
We also have bulletproof coffee.
We just started carrying
Dave Asprey's awesome coffee.
Give me some way that buffalo
jerky. Okay, I'll get you some,
we might have some in the back.
Do we have those boxes, Jamie?
Those boxes of a honored
supplements in the back of, so grab,
grab one of those jerky.
It's really good.
They'll have low chairs.
We have gummy bears for kids that are
made out of fish oil. It's really weird.
They fucking, you would think they taste
bad. It tastes pretty fucking good. My,
my two year old, just not
mine them. She loves them.
She's asking for more and essentially
there's no, they'll a little bit, a bit,
I can taste it, but she doesn't give a
fuck. No, that is, that's, that's buffalo.
That's a, a traditional
buffalo bar where they, um,
they make it with cranberries. Cranberry.
Yeah. And the cranberries sort of,
yeah. It keeps it a, does that
give you a nice chewable bar,
pregnant crawfish and it
explodes in your mouth.
Do you remember?
We were on the road somewhere and
you go into eat the crawfish head and
something blew up in your mouth.
Some of those things,
it was like a fear factor style. You
all spit it up. It was pretty nasty.
Like Donna Martin graduates.
It was pretty nasty. This
is not taste, death, fishy.
These nautical Omega three jellies,
but your kids will eat them.
And it's been shown that fish oil
is crucial to a child's development,
mental development too. And
also mental function. Um,
and as well as a muscle recovery
like fish oil is amazing.
And it's great for joints. Uh, it's,
it's really incredible how much different
you feel taking fish oil. Like if you,
I urge anyone,
if you have like knee problems are
elbow issues or something like that,
try taking a lot of fish oil because
fish oil is incredible for that shit.
It's an, it's an antiinflammatory, but
it also, I don't know what it does,
whether it Lubes your, your, your
joints, it doesn't make any sense.
It doesn't make any sense
that we've loads are joining.
So that's how I like to look at it.
But I think about a doctor I'd make fun
of me for saying that. And it was like,
this isn't how it works. Dumb
ass, but whatever it does,
it's awesome. Um, so, uh,
that's uh, and that's not even something
on it sells bitch. I'm just telling you.
Go get yourself some fish oil. Wait, what
about you don't have any fish oil? Yeah,
for little kids.
Why are this is just for little kids.
Well you could have them too cause you're
kind of a little kid at heart and you
like candy. Like, well
I don't understand why.
It isn't just the idea is that it's
just to trick a little kids into taking
something healthy into their body. It's
a little kids. It's really difficult.
Other adults will take fish
oil supplements because they
know it's good for them.
But why don't they just make it the same?
Like it's a nice way to take it.
It doesn't have to be gross for us.
Um,
because most people are adults and
they don't. They don't. It doesn't,
wouldn't it be nicer to have the
candy as you take it instead of,
I like a big horse pill. I guess. I
don't give a fuck. So you give a fuck.
It doesn't bother me taking vitamins. I
just take them. But wouldn't it be better?
No, it wouldn't be [inaudible]
Chu woman. Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Swallow them. Do you want some of this?
No. Thank you. That's the only delicious.
Anyway,
use a code name broken.
This is the longest commercial for
on and never use a code name. Rogan.
And you will save yourself 10%
off any and all supplements.
Stamp of approval on the beef jerky.
100 Buffalo Jerky. Yeah, it's bad ass.
And this is a 100% money back
guarantee on all of the supplements,
whether it's Alpha brain or shroom tech
or we're only selling you the best shit
we could possibly sell you the best shit
we can find and nobody's trying to rip
you off.
So the way it works is you,
you bought a supplement and you have
a 90 day window to get 100% money back
guarantee.
You don't have to send the product back.
You just say it didn't work for me.
Look,
the Alpha brain thing is especially
controversial because I guess it doesn't,
I don't know what
anyone's body experiences.
I have no idea what coffee does to
you. I know what it does to me. Uh,
I know what works for me and a,
I know it works for a lot of other people.
There's a,
there's a difference between me when I'm
taking nootropics and taking vitamins
and eating healthy and when I'm not,
and there's a difference in my ability
to form sentences for, you know,
for me that's, that's a pretty
important shit. You know,
whether it's doing commentary you're
doing stand up or doing this, you know,
so Alpha brain to me is a godsend. If
I, if I don't have that shit, I panic.
Um, we follow a step behind your
brand. You can feel it. Yeah.
There's some in there. Grabbed, grabbed
that box. Give me some of that shit.
Nutrients,
my friend nutrients for your fucking dome.
This is the honest mini
CFCs rescue by. Yeah, let's,
let's get out of this commercial. Cuban
music. I've done enough of these people.
Use a code name, Bro.
Going to go fuck yourself.
Hello savages. Hello. Great people.
We're so sorry that we're starting
40 minutes late. But uh, this, uh,
this new studio, it has a few
bugs. That's how it works folks.
It's like when you build a car,
it's hot.
We're trying to get it haunted.
We're trying to get some,
I'm an antique clock in here
cause you can get a clock.
You can get a clock from the 18
hundreds and shit. You know, I,
I've found that quite a few of them
online. I just think that would be dope.
Just have the soul. Yeah, some clock
that's been around since the 18 hundreds.
You know, it's nice to have a thinking
after the past. Yeah, I dunno. It's uh,
just kinda creepy and haunted.
I think that's kind of bad ass.
How fast this stuff hit you.
Alpha brain. Um, it doesn't,
I don't know how it's going to hit
you but it doesn't really hit me.
It just sort of ramps me up slowly. It's
not like that in or does it just like,
no, the first pill you could
feel it pretty quickly.
I mean you could take to and
feel a difference. Your, your,
your brain will definitely be stimulated,
but when you take it on a regular
basis that I find if the best benefits,
it's nutrients. You
know, it's a, you know,
new nutrients are very controversial.
There's a lot of people that think you
should be able to get everything you can
get with your diet.
And I say that's kind of silly because
you can get everything we want to get
with your diet,
but you know what you can also do.
You can get everything and then take
some extra shit and be on top of things.
Also, like you can get everything,
but who's going to get over there?
It's fucking hard. You know?
If you like yummy food,
if you want to eat salads, like dude,
if I was, if I was just thing as you,
I would gorge all the time and I'm like,
no,
you stay as thin as me so
you can gorge on occasion.
Yeah. Our got big and
disciplined himself. Yeah,
but then there's Jason Tebow who he can
eat a million pizzas with hamburgers
inside of them and you still won't even
get one little, it's always been him.
Jason Tebow. Yeah. Yeah. He's a skinny
motherfucker. Some people like that, man,
there's, there's dudes who just
can't gain weight. That's awesome.
I talked to [inaudible] about
it. I was like, yeah, it
can't just be eating habits.
I've got to have some sort of better
ability to burn fat than you do.
You said that to him? Well, yeah, we were
talking about like we both love candy.
It's like not like I'm living with the
straight and narrow all the time. Right,
right. It's like I should be, I should
be closer to what he looks like.
How often do you exercising?
Um, basketball. Once a week.
That's it. That's about it. Wow. Yeah.
You don't long to do anything more than
that and that you don't get driven like
you were doing. No,
that's not true. Yeah. No,
I go up and and going up to Runyon
Canyon a lot. Oh yeah. Hiking. Yeah.
That's legit.
It's just gone for the last week.
People make fun of hiking like Ooh was
fucking basically you're doing like leg
lifts,
a little body weight squats over and
over and over again going up hills.
It's fucking Rad in this, in the
winter time like this where you can,
you can really see like for me,
you get up there on the left hand one
you're going to see like all of the ocean
and stuff and the whole city
spread out before you. Yeah.
Yeah. Hiking is fun, man.
I think is really fun.
It's fun to just to get out there
and get away from buildings. Yeah.
There's something cool about
being in the woods now.
It's almost like I'm looking at it like,
man,
you mother fuckers aren't going
to be around here for much longer.
What do you mean by the
woods? Oh yeah. Like there.
They appreciate them while you can,
until the whole thing
becomes like blade runner.
It'll all be chopped down at some point.
Right. We need what for everybody?
I don't know how long it takes to
grow a tree, so long. Long time. Well,
that's another thing that hemp can do.
You can make buildings and the trees that
are stronger than building's made out
of wood. What really? Yeah. Yeah.
It's crazy. It's a nutty plan.
It's really light, but it's super strong.
Like the stalk of hemp, like the, the, uh,
the actual stock of the tree gets
really thick and it's really,
it's a bizarre plant. It's almost like
an alien. He take this fucking thing.
It's super light,
but it's really strong fibers wrapped
around each other and stuff until it like,
well, it's just, it's a
stock like any other trial,
but it's just a really rare type of
fiber and that's why it's makes amazing
clothes and that's why it's
so good to make paper out of.
But you can make a plywood out of it
too. They take that shit and they, uh,
where did they get on with houses
out of it? How do they, uh,
do they get involved with hippies?
What did that match up?
The whole marijuana thing.
Plus hippies want to be close to the
earth and it seems like earthy to be
wearing some sort of truth as opposed
to will be as opposed to wearing cotton,
which is also pretty fucking earthy,
right? Yeah. It's a fucking dipping.
It's another plant.
It's like discriminating against certain
plans at the same shit was way more
comfortable when it's way
better for your underwears. Yo,
if you weren't hamp underwear,
I've,
chances are you're going to get some
chafing and going to get some, uh,
some devaluing and you junk if
you ever have a underwear on.
And then it just,
your stuff hangs a little weird.
So it's just like rubs up and down
against it and you're like, yeah,
you get that weird. Yeah, the Dick
holds and rang as fuck too, man.
That's stupid Dick Hole.
And it rips.
Do you ever have one that rips
like cold dry humping and the
child giving birth? Do you use
it? I try not to. It hurts.
When PMAL do you reach in and grab your
Dick and pull it through the hole? What?
Yeah. No one does, right?
Or does it pull it through the hole?
Pull what through the hole.
It's in your mouth. No, no, no. So
the hole in your underwear, you know,
there's always that pull through
that whole weird house. Oh,
you meant he thought through the bottom,
like where your leg is,
how you were saying pull some sort
of skin out of your Dick Hole.
This is how confusing you,
you fuck just you talking through ours,
your fair? He couldn't understand my quite
rational question. Yeah, totally normal.
Yeah. I pull out through it called
Sometimes I had to pee and stuff. Really?
And then it goes back at,
Yeah, just to pee at urinals.
I don't want to do under the whole thing.
Wow. Am The unbuttoned the fucking belt.
And what if that hangs down?
Like ring around the Rosie or whatever
it's called from just staining of peeing
all night? No one around the whole, yeah.
You would think that that wouldn't be
like this is what it off afterwards but
off.
It's either go back through the middle
or let them let it come over and make it
a fishing line.
Not back through the middle.
We're back to the underwear wrapped
in teaching you how to Bait your hook
back through the middle. I don't, I don't,
I don't need that whole, that
whole is not important. I want to,
I pull my fucking underwear
down like a real man.
But then here's the problem though,
and if you pull that down,
the elastic pushes it up against your,
you're on your ball,
tuck it under your belt,
but then when you pee,
I feel like some of it's being pinched
off. And then when you pull it back over,
but you know what I do is Kinda
rerelease these two fingers right here.
This one comes down and it pushes
the elastic away from my boss.
Isn't that amazing? All my Dick
with one hand and the other hand,
I'm just holding my elastic away from
my boss. It's not that different. Okay.
But wait,
how do you shake hands and make friends?
Then I put the other people well while
I'm in the toilet at the urinals. Yeah.
Well I don't really miss shake hands and
make friends with the urinal, Ari Shit.
That's what I wasn't understanding.
How weird was it when that
congressman or senator,
whoever the fuck he was got busted. I
think about bandwidth, low problems.
So if you're using any bandwidth here
at the studio, let me shut this shit up.
That shit off. I'll shut
it all off. Um, the, um,
the,
what's his name?
Larry Craig because that was his
name was the congressman and he went,
he went to,
yeah,
a truck stop while he was in
a bathroom at an airport. Oh,
airport bathroom was an airport bathroom
that they had been having problems and
complaints with like these,
these really aggressive gay guys had
set up shop and this one bathroom,
this one airport.
And they had like,
they had meetings there and they would
have these little like signals they would
do to let other guys and other stalls.
No, they're ready to fuck. Okay. And,
and the word got out, the word got
out. Well this guy, uh, his name is,
uh, he's Larry cubs a photo. Do you
have to, how do you get up there?
This is all post nine 11.
Yeah. Is it the outside toilets
like with a check? Bags are, I don't
know where it is. You know, I don't,
I don't know. Um, it couldn't be
through security then. No Way.
They're buy tickets somewhere. They're
just not getting on a plane. Yeah.
Or is it known if you've got to lay over
at lax? It might be one of those things.
So it might be one of those things where
guys go there on purpose just to hook
up.
Like they take like fake trips.
There's no number dude. Just go in
there and, well, and then people,
so then what happened was cops,
I believe this is how the story works.
People are getting complaints. So cops
decided they were going to go undercover.
So they went under cover and this guy,
uh,
who would turn out to be a
senator got arrested for doing it,
trying to get his freak on. And he
claimed that, uh, he was trying to,
what is it that somebody tapped his shoe?
No,
he was saying he had a wide stance
or something like that. Yeah, I know.
And that's why he's a,
his legs went under the other guy's
stall because that was the sign.
You'll put your legs up, you tap the other
guy's foot. And that was a sign. What?
It must have been so fun for them before
someone had to come in and start hating.
Imagine you're a senator,
you're talking about how much you hate
gay people and you're talking about gay
people shouldn't be allowed to get
married and then you go to a bathroom and
just some you smell shit.
Why some guys suck in your
cock and like Yay Dude,
you just go to this fun for
them at Chicago, not midway,
not O'Hare and you just go there
and some guy he'll fuck you.
It's probably some sort of form of mental
disease or disorder that someone like
that has, well the gun but a guy
who's like an anti gay, right, right.
That turns out to be secretly
engaging in gay activities.
It's gotta be compensation.
Right.
Just like keeping a public eye public
persona of like going overboard to try to
defend against what you are.
Yeah. A lot of it is that,
and you know a lot of it is they're trying
to convince themselves that they can
control this demon urge inside my loins.
We did it.
We did open mics when I
started opening my ex,
but there was this guy who none
of us want it good, but he,
he did this like self hating gay routine,
but it was like real.
Was he a self hating Gig?
He was like,
do you know what it's like to know I'm
evil to know what I'm wanting is tied to
me is wrong. It was sort of funny, but
it was like, oh my God. The older I get,
the more I think that gay people have
it. Right? What gay people seeing me?
No, not that that too, but also that
they're hanging out with other guys.
They get to fuck and hang out with
guys. You know, dude,
I walked down Santa Monica Boulevard
one day when it's nice out,
I'll take a walk around my neighborhood
and you just see them on their patio
like bars, eating chicken wings and
enjoying themselves and their company.
They're all smiling, they're all
smiling. They're not dealing with women.
There's never that exasperated like what?
What are they even talking about?
By the way, cool women in the world. We're
not talking about you. All right. Relax.
Talking about nightmares. I had
a friend today describe me, his,
his nightmare scenario. What
was it? I can't talk about
it on the air, but it was,
it was so preposterous. If somebody who
was really happening to like, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Just
nonsense fights. And I was like,
whew, you have to break
up with this crazy person.
I was in a urinal last night,
uh,
at the Improv and when I walked in,
the one that only a urinal that was open
was right next to the stall and there
was a guy sitting on the,
you know,
when you could just tell
somebody sitting on the toilet.
And I was thinking about that story about
the guy that like under the foot under
thing. I'm like, I'm just thinking like,
oh I hope he doesn't grab my foot
cause I don't want anything to do with,
I don't know.
I was really stoned and I'm like,
oh that's what briefcases are forced. He
could just like set it down, you know,
like a blocker. Keep somebody from
flip tapping you invented. I bet.
I mean, what a terrible place to
meet to fuck where people, Shit.
So the opposite of romance.
It's just public bathroom,
bath at an airport, be an extra
dirty. Is that what it is?
Is there something about being an extra
dirty boy or do you like it dirty,
like revving the shit out of a stranger?
Some girls like that too. Look like,
oh this is what we're doing right now,
but at least like it's a guy and a
girl are doing like vaginal penis sex.
If a guy and a guy and a shithouse like
they might be fucking each other in the
butt.
And that's what I'm wondering.
I'm like how much butt fucking
is going on where people shit.
Oh like that is because then
the problem would be like, wait,
am I smelling your ass right now
or are you like someone else's?
If you two guys were but
fucking and there was, you know,
just shit all over the place and you
smelled the ship getting like pumped into
the air as this guy was slamming
in this guys. But I mean look,
dudes are sick fucks.
Okay.
There's definitely some dudes who
have fucked some dudes with a shitty,
but there's no doubt about it.
It's not like every gay guy,
this Evergage Nagin the button,
make the shitty smell come out more.
I would in my dream and my dream,
you probably start getting the
like it because it's like your,
your lover's smell and
then you let you start.
Joey Diaz used to have a bit above that
about art and in front of gay guys to
turn them off at the gym. He's doing
yoga. You release it to let him know.
It's like, Ooh, who's that?
Yeah, show ideas. Yeah.
Yeah.
Would have to smell like that and then
you have to smell other people's shit.
It just seems like a really terrible
place to try to get a hard on. Justin.
Justin,
can you imagine if someone gave you,
like if you had like a a prize,
$100 who could go into the bathroom and
do a shitty bathroom and master bay to
climax first?
I think it's the same species that
hangout at like men's locker rooms,
athletic clubs,
and they just kind of hang out there and
talk and like say should have that wish
somebody at some point concept.
Am I going to find someone shitting?
Go on either side of
them and then just ready,
go and then just go in there
and try to jerk off. God.
Could you imagine if he did it publicly?
Liked her?
I think he got to go on a stall because
if you do it like in front of people,
like in the bed, like if you're
in the bathroom, like the urinals,
like if you like having, absolutely
no, that'd be, that'd be weird to them.
Fucked up man. If I do just
start beating off in a urinal.
I did that once in a church.
Watts was delivering flowers.
You went to a church to deliver flowers
beat off in the year and I need to go to
the bathroom and I was like, this seems
like the perfect wrong place to do this.
Wow. That's hilarious. How old are you?
16 okay, so this was before
you got super religious? No,
I was religious center before I
went back to go to Israel. Here's,
were you in Israel? That was right
after I got back from Israel.
That was right after he got
back. I got back from Israel. Oh,
so when you got back you probably will
like over it. I didn't start. No, not yet.
I was still took me like a couple months
to talk to start really realizing those
thoughts were coming up.
Oh.
But obviously wanted to
left the fucking repertoire.
That's data is religious like God,
I never worked its way out.
Was it a Christian Church? Uh, yeah.
Was there a little hate fucking
going on that year at all?
Is there a little of that?
Like a little,
a little better with the Jews are better.
Jews were not.
Come on your Christian
Church churches urinal.
There's on university drive. My crazy
shit is better than your crazy shit.
I used to try to jerk off whenever the
planes, they don't say this anymore,
but they used to say that, uh,
we're now going over Arkansas.
If you look out your window,
they ever do that anymore. Yeah.
Sometimes they do that still.
If it would get really chatty pilot,
I would get up and I would
go. I was like, oh, Arkansas.
I go run to the bathroom and tried
to cross Arkansas off my list.
That's hilarious.
As you're in the sky,
does that count of saying like you had
sex in Arkansas short the list or is it a
masturbation list? It was just like I
where I dropped off. That's probably free.
People think you have to be on the ground,
man.
I have to be real and I was never
going to get to these places.
International Air. Yeah. Yeah. Account.
You wouldn't get to Arkansas. I bet you
have a good fucking time in Arkansas.
Clinton was the Goddamn Gun,
man. I Bet Clinton just,
I have a feeling that he probably had
some good influence on little rock.
I bet if she went there, it's probably
a little rock schools anywhere.
This is a college pretty nice. Cool. Yeah.
I mean if a guy like
Clinton became the governor,
well he's such a bad motherfucker though.
He's such a good talker.
There are still girls that would fuck him.
Like a lot of them.
I hope they still do. Girls that
weren't when he was a president.
I hope there's girls today that
give him a little on the sneak tip.
That's what I hope and they just
know how to keep their mouth shut.
He's the Goddamn president
and have some respect.
One of the greatest presidents
of all time, let them jerk off.
I remember the lady,
I remember being so relieved
when he got caught. Why?
Because I didn't feel like
I was fucked up. I was like,
I felt like I always felt like all
throughout my life like that I was way too
horny. Like what's wrong with me?
Like why do I want sex all the time?
Like you know what, what? And
when I was younger it was like,
why can't I stay in a relationship?
I just so fucking bored.
I would just want to go [inaudible]
whatever it is. Doing well, yeah,
whatever it was. But I'd
always also felt like, man,
I'm just like a creepy person.
Like I'm a creepy person.
Like to have these feelings
and then Clinton, God,
God getting his is sacked by a 20
year old and it was all over TV.
And I'll never forget that. Never
forget that feeling. I was like,
I'm okay. I'm okay. We're men are crazy.
Like so whenever like anything nutty
comes up in the media about any guy doing
some crazy shit. You're like, I know
they're out there. I know they are.
They have to be a,
why wouldn't it be the same percentage
of politicians when all these reverence
guys, things come out and they
see the John Travolta, you know,
tries to fuck on one. He
gives me massages. Of course
he does. What do you mean?
Did you hear about the lawsuit? One of
the guys is suing John Travolta now,
so like I never promised that it
wasn't going to tell anybody. Oh,
he's suing John Travolta.
John Travolta.
Because I guess for slander or something,
I don't even know.
Like the John Travolta
said he didn't do it.
And I think what it was so many questions,
John Travolta guns,
like sick as lawyers on people.
I'm probably offered them some good deals
to shut the fuck up some money, man,
you know, and so then they dropped
the cases or the cases where,
or maybe he paid them off ahead of time.
Just so head on Tony Buddy.
Legally binding. I'll just tell, tell
people you tried to touch my job.
That would be devastating if they did
that. I think he's, he's definitely a gay,
right? Gay. Why is that
offensive? I don't know.
Someone who's PC would totally call you
on that. You know it's also bad. A black,
oh, that's way worse. Way Worse than
blacks. Even at this ain't a game.
A black. You're a black. Wow.
Travolta facing new lawsuit over
gay sex scandals. Slam for Rehab.
Rehab Desk. Does he murdering people
but not really? Loves it. Very good.
Rehab Desk. How is that possible?
I don't know. Let's see.
What can not to do as a coach.
How killings connected to like
something where someone got murdered?
Is that what it's saying? This is the
former pilot. I remember that guy.
That picture of him kissing
a pilot a long time ago.
It's just the former pilot
claims he carried on a six
year relationship with John Travolta
is towing all 62 year old dog.
Go God Berta whoa claims
that he met Travolta Volta
in February of 1981 when the
actor interviewed him for a pilot job
and it didn't seem became lovers. John.
Well, hold on, hold on
right there. Hold on.
It says John Travolta often like
to eat the man's asshole. Oh,
Fox says silly man.
It's assholes too much.
You'd have to say the clinical term,
but wait.
Alleged lover reveals secrets of six year
relationship. Oh, he's not suing him.
Hey everybody.
I'm Stephanie Bower,
Holly's school pilot who claims he carried
on a six year relationship with John
Travolta is telling all 62 year old.
Doug got her ball claim in February of
1981 when the actor interviewed him for a
job and they soon became lovers.
The man makes the wild claims in a story
to the national enquirer from their
first date.
Got Her boss says they became a couple
and travel to whisk him away whenever he
wanted. The last time he saw
her was in 1992 by that time,
the Hollywood actor had
married Kelly Preston,
but he says to roll to told him he's
still preferred men to both his team and
the scandals surrounding him lately.
And this man's story seems pretty
sensational for more entertainment news
checkout, Holly Scoop. Wait, why
does that even seem sensational? Oh,
because that's what they told him to say.
Yeah,
but because before he met his wife,
he had a relationship with another person.
Yeah, that's what they told her to say.
So she said it. Yeah, that's, that's fine.
That's not professional at all.
That's not news.
Just cause he won't say
he likes to do dude.
Sometimes he just doesn't want to
say because it's bad for his career.
Hit the latest updates as John Travolta.
This attorney cause this lawsuit. Right.
Dickie less. Wait, why is there a loss?
Why is it guys suing him? What lawsuit?
That's just the book.
He's just saying he had oh relationship.
You can't sue him for that.
I think that was just the wrong link.
If you worked for John
Travolta for like six years,
would you troll and just say that he
fucked to fuck me [inaudible] software?
He probably would fuck you though.
It depends what kind of situation I'm at.
Probably would try to fuck you.
At least John John hear it.
They don't like you repulsive.
John Travolta is, uh,
is being accused of not
asking someone to keep quiet.
The savages star has been sued by a pilot
and gave an interview to the national
choir in August. Uh, he claimed he had a
romantic relationship, blah, blah, blah.
Doug says he filed the suit for
relief and response to what he says is
threatening letter from your voltage
attorney reminding him that he signed a
confidante confidentiality agreement
upon leaving triple his employee.
Meanwhile got the dirt [inaudible] him
to see he signed a termination agreement
but never agreed to keep quiet.
So whatever.
I mean, even if he did sign it, he
probably would want to release it anyway.
If he's trying to fuck
with Travolta Travolta,
cut it off when he started getting old.
That's fly together that
don't do the obvious gables.
Hey,
do you
know like if you were to have gay affairs
in the sky is the best way to make
sure no one knows?
Yeah,
maybe that's why I tried a pilot.
Maybe that's why it's your role to me,
Kayla,
and then it was too embarrassed about
it because like, no, I'm not gay.
They can just shove them
out the fucking window.
No foul feed it. Could you imagine
if that's what he was doing?
She just have a gay discos and space.
Just the inside of his thing.
It was all like one of those Dexter cut
houses have an all in one stick all over
the walls.
Could have an all in one button autopilot
and disco ball or just come down.
It comes down like instead of oxygen
masks just go, ball comes down,
fleets starts spinning and John Travolta
comes out to stay alive and as long as
it were
pointing at his boner,
he was a bad ass dancer.
That should have been,
that should have been thing number one.
It was amazing. And look who's talking to.
Nah, I'm really, it wasn't
that impressive. Performance
friction was great.
That's when he came back.
Isn't it amazing that one movie just
all of a sudden you're a bad ass again?
Cool enough movie?
Yeah. It's all it takes.
For some people you don't need a lot
of creditors or some people just one.
That's a weird thing.
When the stars just sort of fall off
and they can't do movies anymore because
their name or their brand has
been, that's got to suck, man.
Dan has gotta be a tough
fucking slung to handle. I mean,
it's not the worst thing in the world.
Don't get me wrong. [inaudible] Joe,
fuck what's going on in Syria?
He's poor attitudes, man.
They don't really work as much anymore.
You see that 30 for 30 and
the Brook football players,
not what was broke athletes,
how most football players are broke two
years after that of the league. Yeah.
I think there's domestic
was percent of NFL players.
Within two years we're bankrupt
and 60% of NBA players,
60% they need to do a better job of
actually hand those people, but whatever.
Well, there's also, there's the culture
of trying to keep up with the Joneses,
which is extremely strong with successful
athletes and successful entertainers.
Lamar Odom on the credential and
show fucking mansions. Yeah. Well,
when you see people with a fucking
Bentley, you want to, you know,
you want to let everybody know
you arrived. Just the loopers.
We're just trying to get a job.
It's like you're making 400 grand
a year that that's really good,
but that's just heavy doctor money. This
is jus talk right here. This is like,
you know, this is how pro pro
athletes don't think like that.
That's how they became pro athletes.
They're wild, crazy. Motherfuckers don't,
how can you make it rain
and it's strip club.
That's just such a waste
because you can only,
because at that moment
you can and when they can,
they feel like they're the fucking
man and it's a rush. It's a rush.
It's just sitting with fake money.
Ari.
Oh yeah. I forgot like playing
monopoly money in the middle there
like right here.
And it's like this all fall and weird.
You know what else is weird? The
diamonds that wearing all those diamonds.
That's kind of crazy too.
I remember some Kuleana or something like,
or old dirty bastard. One of those
guys once said he wants to have a,
or maybe snoop dog,
whatever.
You know my point is he said he wants
to have a phone made entirely out of
diamonds and just the insides would be,
the problem is those things are,
you know,
they fucking phone is only good for six,
seven months and then you're going to
want the newest shit and yours is going to
be out of diamonds completely out of date.
Like those virtue phones.
Have you ever seen those? What are
those? Um, who makes that? Brian,
do you know who makes the virtue phone?
I think the guts of it are
that a new voice? What was that? Oh,
there is rip torn son.
Yeah.
It's called a [inaudible]
and they're stupid expensive
man. Things are, you know,
it'd be out of date and like here's
one and $9,000 for a cell phone.
Yes. Yes. It's ridiculous. And by the way,
it's got a little shitty
ass stupid screen. It's got,
but, and why is it 9,000?
Because it's made out of like really
expensive shit. What's the name of it?
It's called a [inaudible] v. E. R. T. U.
It's like one of the dumbest
luxury items in quotes that,
that people choose to indulge in.
But it comes with like executive services
too. Like there's a virtue concierge,
so like you call and they get you a
reservations in restaurants and shit like
that. Just sit right here. So I
guess it's like, yeah, that's it.
So I guess there's like probably some,
uh,
some benefit in that
integrated with those voices.
Son of a stuck in that voice.
Hey, where's the ball? Yeah,
signature zirconium.
They make them with like good,
bad gay boy fucking bad
version of a bad gay boy.
And you know what I'm doing anymore?
This episode is brought to you
by the Skywalker. Oh, Shit. Got,
we've got way too high before the
show folks. I'm really sorry. We're,
we're looking up luxury phones
now. Despite all though. No,
no, no, no, no. Like luxury.
I don't own any diamonds.
Try to hear what that the diamond things
is really weird thing when he's had
those crazy chains that they were
on the neck. What do you mean?
It's like the diamonds.
Hundreds of thousands of dollars on
their neck that's just showing it's
peacocking just showing off your others
showing that you can do that. Well,
if you could walk around
with a house on your neck,
that dude is letting you know he's a bad
motherfucker. But a lot of those guys,
that's why they wind up going like
off the deep end really quickly.
It's real similar to
this. Um, um, perennial.
A potluck comedian of my
community named house head,
whereas a doll's house around his head.
How's head? Yeah. Well he's like
carrot top. Okay. They got that.
I was thinking of going red. I could have
been carried top. What else? What else?
What else? What else? How sad this
is it. I got it. I fucking got it.
He's like a semi homeless. Oh
God. Where's the doll house?
And I said I'm going to be
a pertinent face apartment.
That's the one up them. Eventually someone
had to say those words. Apartment face.
You can probably, they've been said before
but not probably the his house face.
We're just draws like look like Steve's
these two going to look like apartments
down inside.
People going around your chest hair.
You were the one who said that a
apartments in downtown La seems too scary.
Well yeah, I mean little
shits box. It's really sweet.
Like there's really amazing like Batman
style restaurants and you walk in and
everyone's like, really? Class
seem cool. Wow this is really cool.
But then you walk like the wrong way to
your car and it's like you're dead man.
You're like, there's
like just, it's scary.
Like fucking like so many homeless people
and sketchy people and people aren't
drug.
I've never had anything happen
or heard anything happened,
but I get nervous every time I'm there.
Yeah. People screaming at you like, Hey,
you're like,
especially when you're like,
I was walking, I think I
told you this on podcast.
So once when I was walking like Veronica
Richie and imagine walking with her
through this maze of probably maybe
30 or 40 people in one block, all just
you're like, wow, it's kind
of like a walking dead.
You have to shovel a bunch of change
down the street and run when they all go
for it. Yeah. People don't
realize we're not exaggerating.
It's really sounds like
you're exaggerating but
there's spots this it sounds like
total horse was like
the are bigger than up.
I'm telling you there are
spots of downtown la like
nowhere else in the world.
They literally are like a Zombie movie,
but daytime that places alive and fun.
They have, they have homeless villages,
like the entire street is nothing but
cardboard box shelters and homeless.
The homeless community,
like they've jelled together in a
homeless community like no place else in
America. There's no place
else in America like skid row,
you know,
street cleaning day.
It's actually just a bath or
a shower for homeless people.
That's the lay down and that's
going to be taking off my clothes,
treats,
sweeping day shiny on one side.
Or if you get it wrong,
not
cleaning dates, just sweeping thing. And
you just get fucked up on that brush.
There's so many of them. It's hard to
wrap your head around when you see it all.
Did you ever see them, Kevin? You can't
think about it. I'll think about it.
It's too overwhelmingly horrible.
What's homeboy's name? I'm sorry. Mac.
Lindsey [inaudible] you,
did you ever see the Mac Lindsey
footage where Mack went
undercover in skid row? No.
Oh my God. Really? He
did it for Kevin boots.
Movie American drug war. He
went undercover, I believe.
I believe it was for that document as a
fucking homeless person. Masterpass pass.
Well, I was a little dirtier,
I think. Uh, yeah, he, uh,
I mean he's fucking fearless for doing
that man because he was out with those
people. Always hug. Boom. Shaka Laka
we trade shirts with them sometimes.
He's a good dude, man. Good Dude. He's
got some love for people, but his, uh,
that,
that adventure was really weird to watch.
Like that he had night vision on his
camera and he's like lying in this like
sort of sleeping bag type thing.
Watching all these people and filming
though and the street, it's fucking crazy.
I might be wrong about the sleeping
bag type thing. He was like sleeping.
It was amongst, covered up
somehow he was like, you know,
wrapped up and he was laying amongst them.
He was like living amongst them.
Like Jane Goodall.
Not quite like gorillas in the mist
that did more dangerous than the chimps.
Oh yeah. Literally push people on fucking
subway trains. Yeah. Just see that shit.
That's the scariest thing about
those, those things. Whatever.
Brazil is the same thing. It's just
sort of foreign environment. Yeah.
Just feel like someone could
shove me into the highway. Yeah.
Or someone could shut me out of the
tracks of crazy things have happened.
They don't happen that
often. They happen. Yeah.
Like this guy that did this in New York.
I mean, how often is this happening?
There's nothing to lose once every
few years or something like that.
Some nut ball goes crazy and if you
think about how many people are passing
through the subway system in New York
every day, the numbers are really,
really tiny. It's really
relatively, it's very safe.
But for that one guy wasn't fish. Yeah, I,
that picture was horrific. Horrific.
It's a terrible way to die, man.
So what happened? They catch the
homeless guy. Did they lock him up?
But he said somebody sent him,
he said they passed him at the home
as he was leaving the platform.
It's everyone's running towards the guy
and tried to help him and he said the
homeless guy, which was muttering like
God damn mother Fucker, Whoa. Like,
like norm wars for just like that third,
their schizophrenia.
They're just crazy out there.
Yeah, there's a lot of that man.
There's a lot of that.
Are we reclaiming homeless people?
Are we getting them back? Nope. Normal or
do they just die out occasionally. Yeah.
There's some stories about dudes who were
homeless who a figure figure their way
back to a good job, or somebody hooks
him up, he should go to apartment face.
It's just hell.
They just checking out at apartment this.
Yeah. There's some people bounce
back from that, but man, it's hard.
It just can't operate with society.
They're just like,
they're going to go with the opposite
way. Some of them is that, some of them,
a lot of them is drugs. Oh yeah. Burned
them out. Well, they just get hooked to,
yeah,
and the the throw all their money and
they get crazy and they don't know what to
do.
They have no control anymore.
That's a lot of people that are in dire
straights. Yeah, big amount. You know,
I mean there's, there's homeless
people because of the economy.
There's homeless people because of,
you know,
financial difficulty and then there's
homeless people that are just out of their
fucking heads and this
homeless people that are just,
they just can't stop doing
drugs. There's, there's a whole
variety of reasons why
people are homeless, but the,
the type that you see in
skid row or very specific.
What I mean those are the drugs zombies.
They're drugs on me cause that's
what the try so wait. So then,
then the drug deals
have to come down there.
We watched him smoke crack while we're
filming. Fear factor once. Really? Yeah.
It was [inaudible] me and the contestants
were in downtown La and we're in one
of those man carriers.
You know what?
Those baskets that they put on
cranes to lift you up slowly.
The one that Travolta always uses,
he uses that in a man basket.
You won't let it go.
You're fucked three calls,
but you're just waiting for that
one. Good one. I know all the,
all those homeless vaginas feel the same.
Anyway,
the man basket, we're, we're up
in this thing and we're like,
we're like above like the second floor
looking down and watching people smoked
crack realize right there on the
street in the middle of downtown La.
That's such a hard drug. Just
smoking. It has like when you get bad,
like who's nervous to smoke pot?
I don't think that's happening.
Well I guess it's just when you're around
a bunch of other people that do it,
so then it Buckhead was
like the normal shit.
I saw it in Winnipeg when we
were in Winnipeg in 2010 yeah.
I walked walking down the river because
it was summertime. Yeah, so beautiful.
When you smell this like candy,
it smells like candy smell sweet.
That's a path for patch and I always say
it smells like candy when you burn it.
Whoa. Who said that?
My friend Patrick. Oh,
you did an accent has Canadian weirdly
Kaden and he did a lot of coke or alleged.
You're just around it and then it couldn't
believe what it smelled like. Yeah.
You see it and you're like,
oh my God,
that's the a bunch of homeless people
don't crack. It's a crazy thing to try.
Well it's like there's no good
reports coming back like this.
You got to have that.
It's real.
It works out really well for one
person is trying to convince someone.
I'm telling you, man, crack
has got a band name. I know,
but if it was telling you,
I know a part of me would be the desire
if it was around other people were doing
it and go like, yeah, a lot of
successful motherfuckers on crack.
They just keep it a secret.
I'm telling you crack is whack guys.
That's a lot of people say that it
didn't quit Whitney and say that crack is
whack. It's one of the things she said
that made me believe she was on crack.
I know, right? It's like saying we'd
wheat speed or wheat as he'd Paula Abdul.
She didn't know he needed one of
those words work. Hey, all right.
I found out that your name means lion.
Yeah.
I would have just told you that you could.
You should have told me a long time ago.
I didn't know.
That's something you should tell me. Which
part? Ari Shaffir. Ari. Ari Means Lion,
powerful and me and Joe
and me and Jodie Leo's.
And I think that's why
we get together. So, aw,
you should deep. You're amazing. You
should write birthday cards for chicks.
Chicks with head injuries, teardrop
on each one. Hearing the water color,
the flower
crown that folks took
growed Grote and my mom,
my mom just got internet today, like
high speed Internet for the first time,
and it was so real broad band from a,
uh,
I'm really scared now you're talking
to her about the McAfee thing.
And then I just stupidly said,
Oh yeah,
we talked to him on the podcast and then
she goes, Oh, you did? I'm like, Oh fuck.
What did I just talk to on the podcast?
You had them called in. Hell yeah, man,
it's good. I saw you had
that. I was like, wait,
is that the same guy while he's in hiding?
Uh, yeah, that's the same
guy. Wow. Yeah, absolutely.
And it's being shipped back. They're
going to ship them back. They said,
I'm so done with that.
You don't think so?
You think it's the whole
aspect of the whole thing.
It's horrible. It's all right.
It's possible.
You always have the fucking fake radars.
And I feel like lonely girl,
18 or 51 attention,
like I'll make up a story something.
So it was like some, oh whatever.
I don't care anymore.
It's like the,
nevermind you and I was to give you
a reference. You guys would be like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
The Phantom,
I don't know if you guys remember the
phantom that was supposed to be this video
game system that would,
uh,
you just like plug in to your TV and it
would just have every single computer
video game. I remember
that. What happened?
It was just that one of those projects
where they raised a bunch of money and
then we took a bunch of money.
Yeah.
So it seems like that if I have that same
feeling with this whole thing. Oh yeah.
Plus he loves playing
pranks. Right? That guy,
they said he like really loves pranking.
It's just too much fucking and the,
and the believes again, government
with whatever he's leaving from.
They are on the record saying we don't
even, we're not even arresting him.
We just want to question him. Yeah.
Like where he's not even under arrest.
We're not going to let me go through the
plane. We're not going to wait for him.
We're just going to get
them eventually in question,
right?
Yeah. I think they're going to kill
him. Just being on say, I was like,
we won't pay the bribes. What? Why
don't you just then pay the bribes?
I think they'll just think
there's too much attention to it.
I think they put him in jail with somebody
who beats the shit out of him. Oh Man.
But he's also blogging from jail.
So the whole thing just makes me feel
now he's in holding in the other country
matter.
How many times do you get to blog or hey,
you're my space and this holding
cell guys. So if anyone had Wifi,
like a universal fucking airport in his
phone and it would be that guy. Right?
If it's, if he's telling the truth,
he's incredible. Really scary man. So,
but he ran away from America
because of what little lower taxes.
That's not running away.
That's fair.
That's not like no disgrace. No,
he didn't run away for taxes.
Really. I thought it said he ran, he like
got murder. No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
He left America for no, no, no murder.
No, he, he, no, not,
it wasn't that it was that he was
involved in a business that was a,
they were trying to make a sport,
uh, these low flying aerial crafts.
They're like, it looks like a kite
with a motorcycle attached to it.
And these people crashed and died and uh,
he was somehow or another connected,
even though he wasn't flying
those vehicles, he was
trying to promote the sport.
So he got sued by a family.
So what he decided to do apparently
was to just get the fuck.
Doesn't that seem kind of weird though,
if you really,
because if you were in that situation,
you could probably be just like, hey, no,
you shouldn't be held accountable for the
murder you've helped or didn't do well.
I would like to, I would leave.
You would just leave the contract.
I'm not to kill anybody. May
have been negligent. I'm sorry,
but I'm fucking doing 30 years for this.
If I ever went to to get rid of you.
I just like see here.
No,
I don't have the money to just fucking
them up and relocate all of a sudden.
But if I did I'd be like, let's just
call it. Other countries are cool too.
Yeah. I don't know if it
would've picked believes. Yeah,
I think he just figured he'd be able to
like buy a safety net to be able to live
their army.
These people keep them working for you.
Keep a bunch of dogs around
and just live like a pimp.
I think he seems to be more until
they turn their guns around.
He's probably more gangster than we
think he is. Yeah. And now he's after me
cause he's after you and he's like, I'm
adding Brian to the list. He was like,
I'm gonna catch you.
I'm going to get you.
He said something like that in
the interview. It freaked me.
You have a Skype in or call in patch
to throw it through a video of them?
No.
While you're looking at him, I'm
looking at you. Oh, on the screen,
they look like you're looking at
Rogen to say like, what can you say?
I don't know that you have that same
look that the guy behind the bar,
the Tempe Improv used to have.
When you ask her a beer,
they would look over your shoulder
until it left the manager. Like,
who the fuck are you looking at? Give
me a beer. What are you talking about?
Okay. Yeah. Where'd you go? I just
watched you guys spiral into it.
I tried to figure out what the fuck you
were going with this nonsense and just
thought about running out of the room.
Um,
anyway. Homeboys, uh,
in trouble or they might bring them back
to Billy's talking about senator this
going for it. I hope everything
turns out to be perfectly fine,
but there's just too much crazy shit and,
and if you pay attention to it,
it drives you crazy and I don't
feel like they following it anymore.
So that's fair. Well,
the dude is like, I mean,
he's a crazy fucking guy regardless
of whether or not he's guilty.
He's a fascinating dude.
Just by fact that he's made,
is willing to leave society and go down
there to believe and live on the beach.
And this essentially what
he calls a pirate island.
He said it was founded by pirates.
He was explaining it to us like the,
they've always been sort of
corrupt down there and he goes,
they rely on their tourism. That's where
he was hoping he could make a dent.
Oh Man. Cool. Yeah,
I think he was thinking that he would be
able to make such a big stink that they
would realize that he has some power
with the media and you know that he has a
profile image or he was always talking
about moving or Columbia. Right. Um,
he definitely thought to Costa Rica.
I think a lot of people who make money
have thought about pulling all their
money out and going somewhere.
I live in like where the dollar is strong
or something where it's a lot longer
dollars strong and the laws are different.
You Fuck 16 year olds
and that kind of shit.
I mean this dude is 50 it was 67.
He's got a 20 year old girlfriend.
Mcafee. How old is Sean Penn? I
Dunno. He's dating a girlfriend.
Florence and the machine.
Who's that?
She's the girl from Florence and
the machine. Florence. What is,
what does Florence and it's a band.
It's like a really popular band.
It's redhead girl from England,
just like 26. She's 26.
She's taking Sean Penn. Tom Pen. So what,
I'm just wondering, I think it's amazing.
I think uh, Sean Penn is probably
50. [inaudible] maybe least. Right?
Why do you care how old he
is and how old she is though?
Looking at what's possible. Yeah. Is
that what it is? You look at it? Yes.
I can pull this off. I was
like, wow. Just an admiration.
I had a conversation with a friend of
ours that will remain nameless and he was
talking about it as he's getting older.
He's 50 now and uh,
he was talking about young
girls that the girls,
he dates all seem to stay around
the same age. That's a, that's um,
what's it called? That's a, what's
that movie with a paddle around? Huh?
No, the paddles. They paddle
the new graduates at 18.
What movies, Huh? Boy?
17. Oh, I didn't see that.
I don't think there's
a confused the older,
the more they stay the same
age as the Matthew mcconaughey.
Well that is a lot of guys, man, they get
stuck in that one emotional level. No,
I like Hasko girls, something
like that. He was a, a dude
did I used to be friends
with back in the day who uh,
he broke it down like in a really
fucked up way. He's like, ah.
The problem with women that are
older is they know their value.
That's the problem. He goes when they're
young and they're like 20, 21 he goes,
they don't know like how
valuable being hottest.
So you can get like one sort of way
harder than you're supposed to be able to
get. And I was like listening
to him say that. So I was like,
this is a guy that's like for him it's
like the stock market. Like, you know,
he was, he had like figured out some
sort of a crack in the system and like,
so he goes, when I see a
girl, he was just like 25,
26 I just don't want to have anything.
It's too late. 25, 26 it's too
much. Yeah. You heard the latest,
they're saying now that McAfee has
had a heart attack in prison today.
Well he didn't say you had a heart attack.
He said he had heart pains and so they
brought him to the whatever doctor.
They have medication. Some dude
with a fucking chicken foot. No.
So wait, so roles is it, that's a
different guy than the one that's in,
that's McAfee. Yeah. He's got a 20 year
old girlfriend. He said he did stuff,
suffers a heart attack.
How long ago was that?
Uh,
I got pee. You Go pee. I'll be
right back. Don't worry about it.
We're right here and taken
to the hospital. It's a,
it's a fascinating story. The, the, the,
what's really fascinating about it is
that there's this guy who is this really
wealthy man who, uh, has a wild
side to him. He's wild man.
Just from the whole idea of his
airplane sport that he was into.
That's pretty wild.
But you know,
a lot of the people do risky
shit and take risky chances,
but then his drug forum
posts or the nuttiest
yeah, that's the shit that, man, I
think that kind of stuff throws me off.
Makes me to go,
I didn't want to
fall for this.
This is going to be a l l cat at the
end or we know it's going to be like,
what's that? That shit never going to
let you down. Like at the very end,
he's kind of just be like,
guys,
he's going to give a statement to the
press and he's going to just play that
song and then I'll you dick,
you know.
Well,
McAfee said when we had them on that,
all of his talk on that blue,
you know,
blue light drug post, uh,
was all just trolling. Right?
But it's not like,
it's not much of a troll.
Okay.
You know, I mean, when you hear what
these, the drug's supposed to do,
the drug is supposed to tighten
this part right up here.
These things are kind of, they're funky.
They need to be tightened. Um, when you,
when you, when you read the
thread and you, you find out like,
what is it,
let me get off here.
Okay.
Anyway,
what he knew about it,
he knew so much about it.
I mean he knew so much about the
different ways to cook it and separate the
different elements.
And the fact that he had,
he actually had a lab in his yard and
the saying that he was using it to have
sex with monkey sex with 17 year old
girlfriend and he actually does have a 17
year old girlfriend.
I mean the,
the fact that the drug taking would
really be the least shocking aspect of the
story.
The most shocking aspect of stories.
A 67 year old dude and seven sex with
a 17 year old girl in a pirate island.
I mean, you know, I mean there are drugs
like what? Yeah, of course there's drugs,
right? What do you mean? Like
drugs got there before he did,
but that stuff MDPV is legal,
so it's not even like he was
doing anything illegal in,
in believes it's totally legal there. Oh
yes. What's the problem? Well, nothing,
there's no problem. They,
he, but he doesn't want to
admit that he does it or he,
you know, or he denies it. Honestly,
I mean, I don't know. I'm completely,
totally speculating as to
whether or not he did it,
but the story's way more fun if he did it.
If he's out there cooking passed salts
and then bang and a 17 year old, that is,
that becomes a way better story. And it
killed, you think it killed his neighbor?
Uh, I have no idea. He says he didn't,
he didn't sound like a murderer to me.
What do I know?
What is the merger?
Especially if he's having
crazy delusional thoughts.
I can see it if he lives like Scarface,
I could see him getting pissed at his
neighbor was complaining about a dogs.
Yeah, there were, there definitely been
some reports of him doing nutty shit.
Like one guy said he climbed
into his balcony and what sleep.
He was a woke up, like they woke
him up and he was in his own urine.
He was lying in a puddle and he was
asleep on this guy's balcony and he was
claiming that he had jumped over from
his balcony and that he was stuck there
for hours because the,
the federal troops,
the state true whenever for
the country had arrived.
The Billy's police and they were waiting
for him and they didn't move and they
sat out there and he said, I couldn't
move cause I moved. They would kill me.
It was the craziest thing. It was
so weird. It was really weird.
It was talking about how they just stayed
there and stared at him for hours and
hours and then you look at like
what the side effects of MDPV are.
We'll make massive hallucis.
Oh yeah. It sounds like
justifications. Yeah.
Just sounds like at the end of
the night they just walked away.
They just because the sun came up and
you realize your mind playing tricks on
you. The last time I did mushrooms,
we had this fucking crackly tree.
It looks so bad ass in front of the moon,
but then when the sun comes up you're
like, oh, it's just a tree. Yeah.
Was just having a loose their shit
and I fucking, it could see better.
Well that stuff apparently
what it sounds like,
that stuff apparently
it's really bad for that.
Especially when you're
doing it over the p MDPV.
Yeah,
and what's the street value of this stuff?
I don't think it's that
expensive. Really. No.
See all this stuff is pretty
easy to make. You know, that's,
that's where it becomes a problem once
you know like the, the, the bath salt,
the idea behind it is that it's not a,
it's not an illegal drug because it's
an illegal drug that's mixed with
something else, which changes
the classification. So
we're not an illegal drug.
So all you have to do to be,
they sell it and they just
say that they're selling it
for non human consumption.
Oh, that's how, that's
how it's bath salts.
It says do not consume
non human consumption,
but everybody knows they're not
really bath salts. No. Oh No, no.
Everybody knows that it's math and then
you get it and you smoke it or whatever.
I mean you could call whatever,
whatever classification.
But it apparently out of all these sort
of bass salty drugs that they have been
selling and experimenting,
one of them for awhile was MDPV.
It became illegal recently, I believe in
America, but it's still legal in beliefs.
So what he was doing, if he did have a
lab and he was cooking, uh, this stuff up,
although he denies it,
he went through elaborate posts
explaining every single aspect along with
photographs of the extraction, the
beginning really the middle, how to,
and the results, not just how to do it,
the results, the images of the results.
I mean, what do you mean like
taking pictures of the party?
He took pictures of all that. No, no, no.
And take it, not those
results. He took pictures of
rob. The problem with the, you know him
saying that it was all a troll, was it,
this guy is actually taking photographs
of it while it's all happening.
So maybe he was actually
doing something else with,
with either a drug or chemical
or something which is possible.
And he took those photos and
was joking around saying, Hey,
I'm in my fucking paradise cooking bass
salts banging 17 year olds but he is
banging the 17 year old and you know,
see what I'm saying?
It's like it's going on.
Yeah.
So like the bath salts part is not really
that big of an ingredient to the crazy
pie.
It's not like a third.
The bath salts only like 10% it
makes it 10% more crazy. You know,
it just the fact that he's this genius
multimillionaire character who invented
McAfee antivirus software,
but like yeah,
nothing makes him different than like he
can fall prey to fucking awesome drugs.
Yeah. You know? Well you
always got to wonder about it.
Like why would I not live his life?
I have millions of dollars.
Imagine how hard it'd be to date a
17 year old. Like, cause you know,
she would flip into that like, oh my
God, she's just a child once in a while,
like every couple of weeks.
How was he didn't date a mega Lamont
maniac and a fucking 67 who just thinks he
rules the world.
You wouldn't want a day to 20 year old.
And he definitely wouldn't want to
date a 67 year old crazy rich dude.
She thinking blush.
Oh,
she's probably a poor girl that
lives on a very poor island.
Maybe we should just be into older dudes.
Was probably a poor girl.
Lived on islands. Get
somebody who's 40. Relax.
I mean, that's one of the big things
with um, uh, the South Pacific,
like,
uh,
a lot of dudes like go down there and
get like young wives because those poor
girls like a great, they're so happy to
get an American to take care of them.
Like you can fuck I'm,
yeah,
this is not really all about like finding
something you love and getting married
on that, right? No,
I know a dude who's in his sixties and
he met a girl in the Philippines at
fucked her, knocked her up. Oh.
And then he goes back and sees
his kid every, uh, you know,
a few months or so. He flies back to
the Philippines, hangs out with her,
calls her, his girlfriend. You know
what, when he goes, yeah, he's an,
he's an older dude. I mean, I think he's,
he's probably at least in his
sixties and he's got to like,
have this weird feeling like he's not
going to be around, you know, in 30,
40 years. More than most than likely, you
know, who the fuck lives to be a hundred.
So it's, how much is it going to
get to know his child? So, you know,
it's kind of weird because he
had girlfriends in America.
I had a wife and America and
he had kids here, but the,
going back there to see his new kid with
his really young Filipino girlfriend,
it's like, it's really kind of
freaky thing for him. You know, like,
it's just new thing in this dude's life.
He just met her and they did it once
while I think he was dating her a little.
It was there for a couple of weeks I
think for a 60 something year old dude.
When you get a little hot young
chippy that just, you know these,
I don't care if he barely gets to
like understand what she's saying.
You know you don't carry,
she's hugging you and kissing you and
you're like really like just the idea of a
20 year old girl or
however old this girl is.
I don't know how old you can understand
that old man who married Anna Nicole
Smith. Right. I always understand that.
That's why I'm saying that, you know,
he was just fucking having a party.
He knew what time it is,
how you should go out. When I did it,
Veronica, I started doing drugs again,
like I hadn't done mushrooms and like
eight years and I had to relive, you know,
her age group of like experimenting with
Mushrooms and Ecstasy. I'm like, oh,
not this shit again,
I'm pretty much back to where I used to.
That's actually a really funny man.
That's a funny idea. They still enjoy it.
It's fun. Different things. Yeah. Will
they look forward to doing shit like that?
Like Cara who was on yesterday,
Cara Santa Maria who was the whatsapp
concerts and stuff and like they do
things. Yeah. This chick who we had
on yesterday, the Huffington Post,
science editor, really great,
great, great gas. She was awesome.
Really interesting,
intelligent person.
But she was talking about her drug
history and it was all like all these
experiments when she was young, like over
and over this when acid went through,
did the acid and went to my
friend's wedding. We did this,
like all these different things
that she did, you know, on all the,
all these different drugs.
But it's like that was that period of her
life and she hasn't done anything in a
long time now. Yeah. Like we were just
kind of grow out of it. What's that?
A lot of people just kind of grow
out of it. Yeah. And I'll also,
a lot of people start getting stability
in their lives and the last thing they
want to do is go off the fucking
rails for the night and, B,
it's one thing when you work
in as a waiter on Monday
morning and a job that you
don't plan on keeping them as long
as still stolen. Fucking Laos. Yeah,
but that's fine if you are,
if you're trying to get
ahead in this crazy world,
this crazy capitalist world,
you have to be at work on time
and you have to get there.
You have to get some sleep in
you so that you can perform.
You can actually have
a a good frame of mind.
So the boss enjoys your company and wants
to keep you around you productive to
the company.
That's hard to do when you get fucked
up on Payoti and go fuck a dancing naked
to the desert at night.
The next day you have a fucking black
guy because your face had a law because
you thought you could fly and the elevator
on the way to work the next day he'd
be like, what am I doing here guys?
What are we actually doing here? Yeah,
and for her, I mean she's,
like I said, she's the, um,
the science editor for the
Huffington post is the,
or the science correspondent,
whatever her official title is.
It's like a big title.
It's an important position.
So you can't be out there and getting
fucked up every night coming to work and
forgetting what you're talking
about in the middle of a sentence.
That vice magazine and thing of that
guy going to the dog show on acid.
No asked for the first time and going
to the, um, the dog show in New York.
It was great.
Oh,
that sounds like hunter s Thompson
came back to life and entered into that
writer's mind. Big frizzy heritage.
Fucking Rad. And he's trying to like,
and what's your deal? You look like your
dog. That's an, he's talking about his,
like the air conditioner would come on.
It would feel so good at my face.
My favorite all time to piction of
Vegas is a hunters Thompson's fear and
loathing talks about us being fucked
up in the casino when they were all on
ether and calves. Amazing. All on ether.
Yeah, like he took all kinds of shit.
It was just taking everything I whatever,
whatever with filled with
acid and ether and Indian,
they were driving to to Vegas in the
story and it was like right about and
Barstow, the drugs began to take
hold as a sportswriter starts.
That's how it starts. And this,
this was all for sports illustrated.
So sports illustrated thought they were
going to get some story on covering a
motorcycle race and it's dead.
Hunter s Thompson release like one of
the most brilliant pieces of American
literature. Just this crazy
little trouble. I mean it's crazy.
It's brilliant and it's all about drugs.
It's all about the Chi being fucked up,
having a good time. And it was the
first time like in, in that era,
a lot of what drug use was,
was like the more annoying shaded.
Yeah. That's so mainstream.
A lot of people associated drugs with
like drum circles and sitting around
holding hands and hit the shot to deep.
Yeah.
Lying down on Indian rugs and that music
and Thompson instead at a red
Cadillac and fucked up on acid.
Just driving around with a cigarette
holder coming out of his mouth.
He cigarette holder. He
just, it was another one.
It was another guy that to me. Let me
know that I'm okay. You're fine. Yeah,
I'm fine. Yeah, because the, the,
the nuttiest fucks amongst us all get
derided before they eventually get
accepted. How bad you think you
worked for masturbating? Yeah.
I'll tell her at some point you're like,
I'm a horrible human.
He just think this is going to be the
last time I'm going to quit. Yeah. Just,
yeah, exactly. I'll just, I'll stop. I
can handle it next time I'm going to quit.
I don't need this in my life anymore and
they just need someone out there saying
like when I was younger than
my masturbated. Oh. Oh, okay.
Nobody even brought it up to me.
It was never even discussed. They got
to, I get to talk to your kids about it.
Fuck yeah, I'm have your
girl do it. Absolutely.
Let them know it's just normal.
And not only is it normal,
but you probably should do it because
it will help you make better choices.
It was like, well, I make them
go through that horrible time.
Just want to rely on one other person to
be like your drug dealer when it comes
to sex. Especially when you're a young
kid and your hormones are on full blaze.
You're just too embarrassed
to talk about it.
And that's why you confuse all the time.
You're making shitty choices cause
you're always horny, you know?
So you're hanging out with girls you
really shouldn't be hanging out with.
You're doing things you really shouldn't
be doing just because you're so
desperate to get this drug. That's sex.
When I was 17 years old, dude, yeah,
when I was 17 years old, I got
hooked on posting. It was a drug.
There's no question about it.
My parents showed me,
why did you lose your virginity?
Like do they really know?
What do they grab your deck? Stroke
it and that slot no slope. Brian.
Don't be eager. When did you
lose your virginity, Brian?
1515 yeah. Why did you lose
yours? It was around then too.
I don't think it was right before I was
16 who was in like 15 and 16 like right
with who was it with you? But there was
a girl who I've fooled around with it.
I could have fucked,
but I panicked when I was 13 she was
still the local neighborhoods slut,
the Hoochie Mama. She was
21 and I was 13 wow. Yeah.
And you would've, you could've
done it there. Yeah. Yeah, totally.
Nerve wracking panic, complete
panic. And by the way, I,
when I was 13 I really didn't
know much about getting hard on,
so really had no idea what that was all
about. That really was like a completely,
I me every now and then I got
one like, okay, there it is.
But I hadn't started the
masturbation process. What
that was going to do for you.
The harder, yeah. I
didn't start masturbating,
believe it or not until after I
had sex. Yeah, me too. What? Yeah.
Yeah. Well, I didn't like it at
first because that was just like,
this is a pale comparison to sex.
Yeah, it's a pale comparison.
But I realized then that I was having
a hard time seeing things clearly.
I was realizing like, wow, sounds
pants up waiting my whole life.
I've always been a very reluctant to
get stuck in like some situation that I
can't get out of any,
any kind of situation that I can't get
out of anything that feels like, oh fuck,
I'm not even commitment,
but something that I feel where I'm stuck.
I'm in a needy position, you know,
I don't like the apartment. Listen,
shut the fuck up.
Jesus Christ here.
So when I first started
getting sex from this girl,
I wasn't panicking cause I
need sex all the time now.
But you need to look at it from her. I
needed to get it all the time, but I,
and then dealing with her was craziness.
She was nuts and you know,
she was also fucking other dudes,
you know,
like she would like fuck my friends and
shit. Like this girl was crazy. We tried.
Anyway, you try to make her, um, get
a lot of questions there. Anyway,
my point is once I started
jerking off, I realized, Oh,
I could do this on my own.
Like I don't need to only be
around this crazy girl. You know,
you don't have to intern about
situations. Exactly. Exactly. Wow.
So you didn't do it before that? No, no,
no.
My problem is I,
I thought you were supposed
to use Vaseline because
of ice cube where somebody
used to always say like,
no Vaseline and shit.
So I thought that's
what you use the master.
But I didn't know there was like
lotions and stuff like that.
So I remember it was just really like,
this is not, you know, like it was not,
it did not feel good.
I, I would, uh,
I would just pull my pants
down around my ankles or my,
my knees and I would just let my cock
rest on the bed and I would just move up
and down with my ankles to give slight
pressure and feel until it would just
come into my belly and shoots. Well. Yeah,
I started off pills before I did my
hand for like a good five years. Well,
how many people must fuck silk
sheets feel wonderful. It gives kids,
yeah, they do. I had some silk underwear.
I used to rub it against that
silk underwear. A fantastic,
you beat off of Phil Silk Underwear.
It's almost as good as beaten off
with like Vaseline, homeless people.
I never got that into lotion.
Homeless people should sell
their bodies more. Okay.
You know, or they should like take care
of like cleaning themselves out and like
prostitute more like you don't really see.
Yeah, there you go. That's a good
fucking idea. Brian. You went crazy.
People blowing you.
I saw in Montreal I saw a homeless
lady and a homeless God boyfriend,
girlfriend. Uh, they were hanging on the
alley behind a club soda. And then, uh,
I was like, oh, that's nice. At least
found that somebody, you know. Right.
But then the next day I saw that girl
was somebody else. Oh, that dirty bitch.
Yeah. Yeah. She was just, she wasn't
cheating. She was just a prostitute,
homeless person. Do they work
at the six bucks it takes to to,
to get that wonder what a homeless
guy has to get like two cigarettes,
much homeless. I don't know what it
would be. I don't know. Price wise.
I don't know.
We had Victor Conte on the podcast.
He's are the the storage guy and he
was telling us that there was a certain
security guard and the Gal that he
was at that was turning tricks. Wow.
She'd make money by banging
the inmates. Really? Yeah.
It was like minimum security people
that like fucked up business.
They did like creepy shit but
college they weren't dangerous. Yeah.
Greedy bitches. So they probably had
money so she made extra money by, yeah,
I don't have a cash back and get
you a check and I'm good for it.
Blowing guards that would
make prison way better.
That's an that really
butchy girl did an odd,
she would always jerk him off in the,
in the maybe a lot of yard time. Okay.
Any activities like with Tommy
Chong described, he described it.
He was at the same place.
If they gave you a like a lot of like
freedom and you get blowjobs from hot
guards, that sounds like
it'd be a good place to live.
She says he's John
Travolta was the warden.
That sounds like a lot of people
would be like, let me just stay here.
She was hot picture context one. Yeah,
she said she was, he said she was hot.
She said she had big tits.
Tits would be sticking out
of her dress and he was hurt.
He fuck is going on or Brian you
trying a little too hard too.
I wonder if talking about guy guards and
I think that you're talking about girl
guards. I forgot. And he was uh, he
was saying that this, uh, this chick,
like he didn't know what the hell is
going on, like what's up with her?
And he goes, Oh yeah, you want some of
that? He was like, what do you mean?
It's like I could, I could arrange
that for, you know, she's a,
she's x amount of dollars
and she comes and dude,
was it a challenge over time out? What
are we talking about? No, look normal.
Regular hooker prices. Yeah. Yeah. I would
imagine the $500 somewhere around there,
maybe even a thousand for like you get
the shooting her eyes or she knows these
are all rich people can't make it worth
the time that I was and you shoot it up
her nose. Special requests. Yeah.
I wonder if girls have things like that.
I wonder if he
wants to do that because somebody
thing definitely this somebodies thing,
the coming in the eyes thing in
porn is like the shooting loads,
all of a girls' faces and all
of their eyelashes and shit.
There's something really nutty
about that man. Something really,
if someone wants to do that for
sure they want to stick the little,
that little penny hole right up to the
nostril and just shoot it right in there.
Geesh.
Make it come out the other night and
know that I'm not even saying something
that's original.
I'm sure someone has done,
there's probably a whole website dedicated
to it. Cocks, not glocks probably.
I wonder if you go to cox.com let's see.
Let's just go crazy and go to Cox.
Not Cox. Not. That was a,
that was a tagline. You're
getting me for a joke once.
Yeah. That's a nice name
for your loads. Your
one. Oh, look at this. [inaudible]
is one of those websites.
It's not really a website. When you
go there, it's like watch adult cams.
Casual sex for gay men because
they know someone's in the Cox.
Not Exactly Alaskan Fire Dragon.
No, I'm not going to do it.
I know what that one is. Yes.
I've been to that website.
You son of a bitch you would already
see with the story of the boy who cried
wolf. Yeah. Ladies at home
or walk over to that junk.
Go to that site. Okay. Don't need to see
that. You don't know what it is he showed.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Blame
the new guy. Cocks. Not.
Maybe it'll start up now.
If there's anybody out there
that wants to start car by Cox,
not.com and you consultation
and what would be the best Cox,
not videos.
I did at one time where a girl let me
tire up and then I all over her face and
stuff. Whoa. It was really hot.
Whoa. Yeah. Whoa. What? What?
What's up with this freaky bed? She's just
like, we had done it a bunch of times.
She was like, she was her
idea. What a good carer.
She had a ball gag. She had the
whole, Oh, she had a ball gag dude.
It was a real used and
shit all busted down.
She works at a ball gag
was like two years old. It,
it was someone who had been
thrown into a rottweiler,
locked up flowers,
fucking stray hairs all over it.
Lipstick from a 10 different shades.
Mother take it was dirty as fuck.
She been getting ball gag and horse
fucked for decades already comes along.
He's like, oh, I just
happened to have a baguette.
It was all brand new from a porn shop.
You got a bucket this,
what'd you drag this behind?
A fucking truck. They chip it.
Chilling on that thing
has a ballgame. The edges. What?
A chick pulls out a ball gag.
One of the first things you think,
is this going to be my wife?
This is not gonna make it. This one is
not. She's not going to hit the big time.
This is
unless you're that guy.
I mean that's gotta be fun for a
while. Yeah. And then by the way,
I'm not your guy either.
You gotta find the right one.
Just someone out there that loves that.
She's like,
he doesn't have his own ball gag people
that love the whole cuckold idea.
Kuk Holding is like big in this country.
A lot of people that are into it,
very about it. But behind that, the
man's, why don't you explain it for,
cause there's a lot of people are be like
hearing, it's when you, it's when you,
well,
there's a type of porn by it.
But the real thing is when you
watched the woman you're with, um,
get fucked by someone else, like watching
you say black guy, wife get fuck. Yeah.
And the W in Brian's talking
about is fucking bookmarks. Uh,
because it's embarrassing. They said a
black eye is worse because it's like,
there's Mandingo like stuff going
in with Eric too. Like my poor wife,
she's really good and she's taken it to
this guy and she has to watch it. Now.
There's these porn of it where it's,
you see a guy watching his wife get
fucked and that's a weird another because
then you're not in bed.
You don't feel bad yourself.
You just feel bad on his
behalf. Yeah, we'll get you
off, man. That's a weird thing.
Like that's what I want.
Yeah.
It would have to be POV to the camera.
A saying I never loved you.
Oh and less.
It's all black dudes who are downloading
that type of porn and they love the
idea of giant Dick and
humiliating this weeks off.
I know there are some dicks
online I reviewed, uh,
I went back and look over
the Kim Kardashian sex tape
recently with open eyes
and I forgot how big that dude's
Dick is. Holy Shit. Really?
She's two fist in this guy's cock
with plenty of room [inaudible] room.
He has a giant Dick. I
mean this, we're talking,
this dude has a 12 year olds hands.
I don't think,
even if her hands are tiny,
this guy has a monster of a duck.
Yeah, I mean it's like, I believe that.
I forgot how big it was. I was like, man,
maybe I just blacked that out because
I was blacked that out. Get it.
No Pun intended,
because I just a,
I was just terrified of
my own inadequacies. Yeah.
When you're watched that,
because that's where that whole
thing comes from. So yeah. So pop,
it's supposed to get you harder
because this is what the, the, the, um,
I guess chemical reaction to it is whether
or not the nature of what's going on
in your brain really is that you have
to compete to have your sperm live on so
you get extra hard.
So you could fucking pummel that.
And this head of your dick is shaped like
a plunger so you can get his sperm out
of there while you're fucking her and so
then your sperm will go in more. Yeah.
That's the whole idea of the mushroom
cap. That's what makes you hard. Yeah,
that's exactly what it is.
Yeah. This guy, Ray Jay,
he really hasn't worked
much since it's video.
And my theory is because he's been
banging 30 to 40,000 girls day.
Once they saw his giant
Dick and he probably said,
why do I even need to keep making music?
He probably is making music. I'm just,
he was on some a, B, I think he was
on some bt reality show. Please rage.
I don't slip me comedians and Dick
and stuff. You don't need a job.
Smacked me in the face with your
giant cock. I was just joking,
but you could still get it. It's
on these free porn sites. Do that.
Would you let them do that for you?
What? Slapping your face for charity? No,
for charity. We're going to fight or
slap me in the face where he'd deck.
We're going to war $1
million for cancer research.
I want to get you back when you can't
slap me in the $100 million for cancer
research.
I'm not really buying all that research.
I think a lot of coastal awaken search
going on. I'm going to, I'm
going to pull this. I can't.
We can't show this on the
Internet because you stream is,
even though it is dead. Don't censor
us. Yeah, I'm pulling it up right now.
Even though the stream does not us.
They're awesome, but they still,
they can't. You can't. Someone can be at
work and then accidentally you get this.
Oh, we're gonna know that this was
shaped like a thing can angry man.
It's so stupid. Why are we living
by dumb people's roles? Well,
because Ray J's dick is safe for work.
It's classic. Not Safe for work
here. The thing that shit up. Oh
yeah, you get, did you do that? You son
of a bitch. Look at the size of this.
Wow. She's really spreading
her mouth apart. Yeah. Do.
But look at the length on that goddamn
thing. I mean the width is pretty normal.
Hey Brian can have that on camera. Yeah,
I sideways. It just looked like, no,
it didn't have been eating a pop shot up.
It didn't want to see it.
Why do you ruin things for
me, Brian? Brian, you can't
have it on Ustream. Dummy.
That's bad. That's bad for everyone.
That's bad for business anyway.
That's pretty good.
Don't get all horny.
Now look at you thinking about beating
off. While she was excellent form,
she was going for it.
Amazing that that led to the
beginning of a very promising career.
She wasn't prissy about it. Like
Nicole Tilton or Paris Hilton. Yeah.
Paris Hilton wasn't fucking a black guy.
Was fucking some weak white dude who
had to put up with their bullshit.
Rayjay doesn't put up with
bitches. Bullshit. Oh yeah.
It's a big giant deck and you got to suck
it and you're going to turn your phone
off. Okay. No fucking text the phone.
That's probably the last time she had
sex without texting was when they made
that video. I bet she's just constantly
checking our Twitter, texting.
I bet you he's the only guy to keep her
in line. It was like, I'm really busy.
Of course I gotta check my texts.
I listened to these two chicks talk about
about her. It was really interesting.
I don't know them. It was at an airport.
They were like, they were, I wasn't,
you know,
it was like one of those situations
where like you're facing that way and
there's people from behind you
there sitting those rows of chairs,
the airport and they're right next to you,
but you're not,
you're not even looking at each other.
How does an inch away from there?
But you're right.
So she was talking about,
I knew that she was talking about Kim
carnation and right away it's like she's
always dating these big athletes.
Like it's always,
it's like most often black guys.
And then, and then just said that,
I mean for real,
she's never going to date a regular guy
now because they're going to realize
that, you know, she read what she really
likes is those big black athletes,
you know? And the other girl
was like, Oh yeah, oh, I know.
Like were like talking logic to each
other. Like she made a bad move.
Like that's what she was saying.
She was almost saying like,
like she ruined her
opportunities in the future.
Those girls don't think they can
get those big black athletes.
So I think the idea is,
yeah,
those girls get a regular guy and for
a lot of crazy bitches, men are like,
it's like playing musical chairs. Like
they look at like what they got to marry.
You gotta marry well,
you got to find a good one to get some
regular white dude from regular boring
guy and the fucking, well she might, she
might have to one day. That was what,
that's what's what these
girls are thinking.
These girls to think
that she might have to,
that she might get some situation which
got to marry some media mogul that
happens to be five foot four,
which at the Mary,
anyone rotund because rich shit
falls apart now rich anymore.
The shit hit the fan and now this poor
little tiny guys going to always know
that she's likes these big giant super
athletes. Fucking the shit out of her.
Like who is that one dude though?
The one black football player that she
was dating for a while. Very famous guy.
Reggie Bush. Reggie Bush. Reggie Bush
owns my old Barracuda. Oh really?
Yes. He bought it. He think he found her
in it. I hope so, but I don't think so.
That would be an honor.
Um, but I mean that's,
that's a guy like you look at
the way he's built. He like,
he must fuck her almost a death,
you know?
And how do you go from that to like
a regular guy? You don't, you can't,
she stuck.
But now she's dating Kanye West and
Kanye has gotten to be thinking about the
fucking Bush put on that.
He's gotta be,
but Reggie Bush, Connie, you probably
is this a thing and like that circle,
that famous black circle of like,
they all want to date the same people.
Everyone's trying to date. Riana I
want, it's their turn. Well there's a,
there's like a benefit to
dating Kim Kardashians.
Like a clear benefit when it comes
to get more famous. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well you guys doing over there?
Brian's everything. Okay.
And Lamar Odom is terrible in
basketball now. Izzy, he's terrible.
And is it because he's like
a famous Kardashians now?
I mean, you always hear it.
You ever hear those things?
I'm certainly seen UFC too,
where it's like his head's not in it.
He's got to focus and you're like, no,
there are professional athletes. They
but it's like no there focus gets robbed.
Well it's fun. Especially like
discipline is a real issue for athletes.
So it's very, very hard to
stay disciplined and train
hard and do your, you know,
your, your time in practice
room when you're not,
your focus has got to be on it during
the extra stuff you do the extra stuff
like strength and conditioning
and the practice when you're not,
it's not in season.
And when here like jet setting all around
the world banging a car dash and man,
I bet. Yeah, that becomes your
focus and checking your Twitter.
It definitely steal some focus.
And when you look at the highest levels
and you're starting to it hitting your
thirties yeah, for sure man, that
fucks no fucks with people's heads.
And the fame you get from
everybody knowing you,
you're way more famous than the other
basketball players on your team. Right.
And you're famous for being a guy
who bangs a cardiac Shan. Yeah.
So you're in this weird group,
you're the most famous non rapist on
your basketball team. And you, well,
how dare you, and he was acquitted
wasn't here. It wasn't never trade.
Your spotter off does not
testify. You could do that. Yeah.
And then she won't testify. There's
no case. The um, the thing is like,
he must be like looking at Bruce
Jenner and he must be saying that's,
that's what's happening. That's my
future. I'm going to just center.
It was a top level athlete. Fuck. Aa was
gold metal winner in the Olympics. Man.
Hero hero on the cover.
We some goofy ass for it.
Did it help us defend
the fucking Dakota's?
He fought off the ruskies
understand with a javelin
and a good jumps more than another guy.
Yeah.
It's one of those weird sports and
nobody gives a fuck about decathlon or
something like that. Such a killer fucking
bit about that. Which normal horse.
Oh yeah. You just whip out
only for Olympics. Yeah. Yeah.
We're going to have it for like a single,
it's like seasonal commercials.
They do those,
I'll blame for like five years,
but only for like two weeks at a time.
I could probably still do that.
Probably the Olympics or Paralympics.
Especially location and it's so poignant,
stupid ass.
Why are we looking at this?
You would never watch most of the sports
during the Olympics if they were on TV
every weekend.
And New Buddy caterers that comes from
a time of when you were like roof the
white fighter over the black fighter.
Cause like the drummer will always
beat the black and uh, in a battle,
doxing is a thinking man's sport.
Well that was why I was a big deal when
Max Schmeling knocked out Joe Louis,
it was a huge victory for the, not for
the white people. White people too.
And that's why they get so mad at when
Moses or whatever his name is, this,
the printer, uh, in Munich. What'd he
do? He in front of like the Hitler,
he likes and won the gold medal and it
took the American flag and like waved it
in front of Hitler. Oh really? Yeah.
It was like a black guy in Munich
or something like that. You know,
maybe he fucking made Hitler
ticket to the next level. Yeah.
I think that was the limits when all
the Palestinians killed those Israelis.
Could, you know that was the
Munich Olympics wasn't it? Was it?
But Hitler was before that. Oh yeah.
Yeah. I wouldn't have been Hitler.
Hitler was in the forties. It might've
been during the rise of Hitler. Yeah,
you're right. Yeah. Um, or
they got the back there again.
Yeah. The Munich Olympics,
when they,
the Palestinians killed those people.
I believe it was in told Sandra Mondays
he gave hill in the middle finger. No,
he did not.
Did Not.
Jesse Owens gave Hitler Middle Finger.
I don't remember that.
That would have been
talked about a weird thing.
It must be to be a runner and hoping
that everyone was going to protect you
while you're running by
just a crazy dictator. Yeah.
Just one of the great minds
of dictatorship and military,
like,
like ruthless military campaigns.
Brendan Burns always says
that he didn't think,
he didn't think a Hitler
would have been mad about it.
Can you just would've thought
the Americans were cheating
by using animals. Oh,
he's an amazing that they were really
trying to devise a master race.
Like that was her, that was something
that people were agreeing on. Like, Yep.
We got to do this right. We
got to do this. Right. Yeah. S
a part of me sort of gets that though.
Well,
there's a lot of utility out of
things over aggression. Sure.
If he said we don't value as a
society, yeah, I can breathe that out.
I would like to, yeah. And if you could
really figure out a way to get, well,
we're going to have to do some work.
It's going to be ugly.
We can get the world to a beautiful
place where there's virtually no cons.
And now that we have revamped
the entire education system,
we can ensure that future generations,
we're also not be cons,
but the only way we can do this as we
got to kill all the cuts because the cons
make more cuts.
So we have to find all the cons and figure
out a way to not make contacts out of
the bay from the, uh, the sterilization
shots. It's not just that,
because they cannot turn
the kids in the top kids.
They turn those kids into cons. Yeah.
If you're around a family of cons,
it's very hard to not be wanting.
If your next door neighbor was
fun and a bunch of like assholes,
probably not going to learn from that.
Yeah. If you live in a horrible yeah.
Environment.
I mean it's probably very difficult to
be a philanthropist when you were in
Liberia and you're struggling
for your life, you know,
my sister was told I curse.
I try not to, but I curse
my normal length. Try not to
try not to around her kids.
Oh right. Or Orthodox children.
How old are they? Like
13 or 14 and the 12 and like whatever.
But it's like they must be so
excited when uncle are sober. Try.
But at the same time it's
like, well, it's not that bad.
It's just a word that I think should
be part of their vocabulary. Do they?
It's better. It's a better word. Why
would you hide vocabulary from someone?
It's nonsense.
Allow them to know what's right to use.
Yeah. It's a stupid, stupid old thing
that doesn't make any sense. And you know,
the idea, I mean, this is like
Lenny Bruce covered this shit
in the 1960 [inaudible] going on.
It's still the same.
The fact that it's 2012 and we still
have magic words gotta kill off the
Christians, man. Well, the
craziest thing about the, the,
the censorship of these
magic words and said,
now they've made it
incredibly expensive to do.
Like if you go on,
go on TV and you violate those for real,
nobody cares about it.
Only has power because we say,
[inaudible] who song doesn't curse out?
It doesn't believe how fuck.
Yeah.
Well that's what a Lenny Bruce,
his argument was about the word
nigger in like 1960 was saying,
you know what the problem is? You know
that that word can still hurt someone.
The reason why that word hurts someone
is everyone's afraid of that word.
You just said it enough.
It would never be able to hurt some,
some young black boy. Yeah. You know, I'm
a young black child. It was a really, uh,
interesting that this guy figured that
out in the 1960s and an error where you
realize very few people thinking like
that in Israel. Nobody uses that word now,
which wasn't the derogatory word. Oh,
that's, and she could just say it.
People were like on
whatever. So, but yeah,
that someone talked about that when they
get off the plane. Who was that? Brian?
Someone talked about on the podcast that
they got off the plane and they said it
because you can say it there. We used
to say it in the streets to each other.
Maybe it was me. I don't
know. It wasn't saying,
if someone was saying that whenever they
land they say it out loud because uh,
in Israel doesn't mean anything.
They get off the plane.
I got it. There might be someone
on the plane still though.
Even just stopping and American black
guy like check around first. Oh yeah.
Okay.
Kardashians.
No black people let it ride.
Let's go. Let's have this. Indeed.
Indeed. How am I going announcement?
Yeah. What's your name?
I'm recording my special
now. Do that. But no, not that. Not
this right now. It seems kind of rude.
I'm just doing it. I'm typing it
in and it's doing one those men,
my next blank man. Yeah. Right now,
if you were doing it right now, say,
I don't think you're giving it your
best effort. It seems like you're,
you're also having a conversation.
You do both. It's like,
I think our standup needs work.
It's December 28th at in Brooklyn,
New York at the knitting factory.
I'm doing two shows.
The knitting factory tickets
are on sale now and that's a,
that's a short amount of time since
you've done your last one. It's, it seems,
well I tried doing it like in uh,
October of last year and then I
didn't record it again until May,
but I put this stuff away,
put the material away when
I thought it was one in May.
And now you're doing another
one in December. Yeah.
But the main one was from
October's material. Right.
But that's still pretty
impressive them writing.
What made you decide to release
it so quickly? Like I said,
I was going to do it a year.
From what I tried to start in the first
one and see if I could write an hour and
a year having a game. Right. You're came
around. I dropped all the old material,
all this stuff on the album was all done.
I only did it again for a month to get a
fresh. Now when you go and do like, um,
if you have like an exploratory set
like okay, this is all new shit,
I'm going to go up there.
And do you do that during
regular headlines sets or
do you set aside til I get,
I get, well I had the luxury of of
the first album didn't come out right.
So I was building material and I could
still do the old material if I needed to
for a paid gig. It's like I got to do
45 minutes to an hour. Right. I got it.
I got to reach into the well,
right, right, right. But
for any 15 minute set in la,
it's like I can get there without this.
It took me like a month to bill to do
the first like 12 minutes to when the
light came on and I was still
doing the material. That's cool.
That's like well over a month,
like two months.
But uh,
yeah,
I guess it was not there.
It's kind of cool how
sometimes that happens though.
Like I, I once you started,
it just kept coming out of me that knew
strip clubs story that I talk about
going to Dayton,
Ohio,
which the owner just died the other
day of the living room in Dayton, Ohio.
So I'm sorry if I cursed you. Uh,
but that story and the dolphin,
this dolphin bit I did,
it just added like almost 10 minutes
to my act and just one weekend.
Yeah, that can happen, man. You can get
one idea that just really takes off. Yeah.
That's,
that's my favorite time when they just
get longer and longer and stuff. Yeah.
You just keep adding your time. My friend
Mike's store, this comedian in Maryland,
he was like, well, you know, I still have
new stuff I want to add to the old jokes.
Right, right, right.
My theory is that same creative energy
you can just shifted to new jokes. Yeah,
totally. The only reason
you're all writing stuff for
old jokes is cause you're,
that's all you're focusing on.
Yeah. But then there's always like,
the problem is when you release a
joke and then right after you do it,
you gotta have a new tech line,
excuse me, new tag dot doing it.
It's like done with it.
So once I get enough,
like enough to like go on the road with
and it's like, okay, we're fine. And then,
uh, you just weed out all the other stuff
until you don't have to do it anymore.
So now you got it to the point
where you're super happy with it,
you're ready to go.
I'm at the point where I'm on the road
now I'm deciding there's still bits I
can't do cause I don't have time for it.
She had a lot of change a lot when you
started getting like long headlines
and that was the first time I've ever
done that. So I consistently did it,
started doing an hour five times
a week instead of 15 minutes.
Seven or eight times a week. Yeah.
Yeah. Plus the 15 minutes in town to,
to fuck around with, you
know, the Tuesday, Wednesday
sets. Those hours sets are,
wouldn't you really get to stretch out?
Yeah. You got that all the time. Yeah.
Yeah. How much material you can just get
to all the stuff you're working on. Yeah.
I was doing that even back when I
lived in New York. I really, yeah,
I didn't believe in those little sets.
I would say I would see this guys that
do the sets in town and one of the,
one of the things that I saw that was
a pattern was that, uh, a lot of them,
although they were great comics,
they were doing like jokes.
It was there basically saying a lot
of things that didn't really happen.
And they were,
you know,
writing a bunch of really funny stuff and
they were setting up and it was almost
either impersonal or it was very
worky. The crowdy. Oh, right.
You know why they set it up? Yeah.
There, you know they would like bring,
it was like they were very tight clubs
and they're very small stages and the a
quick,
oh yeah.
How long would you get back down if
you were lucky you got 15 minutes.
I think danger fields
would give you the longest,
I don't remember it was 20 or 30 minutes.
Danger fields gave you like a real set
that was the only place in town that
everything else was like the most,
you would get us like 15
minutes or something like
that. Sometimes it was seven,
sometimes it was 10 but those are
hard because it's all you get.
It's like well I only have one or you
can total it. Like look at a towel.
It's hell came from that world
and it's brilliant. It's just his,
but his act is that style of,
you know,
a bunch of shit that's not
really happening. And then
a clown came out and bloom.
Hey, but some guys do like
long stories that come out
of there too. Very few. Yeah.
It doesn't seem like that. But they don't
do, they do 15 or 20 minutes. That's,
and you know what those stories
out and, and doing the road. Yeah.
The road is where it comes out the road.
Like those long weekends when you're
doing four shows in a weekend, five shows,
we do an hour in la for years.
Yeah. Nobody really does that. Yeah.
That was lucky too.
And um,
and then there's all the satellite rooms
around la that's always thrown to the
Bray Improv ice. Yeah. Yeah.
We have a good spot right now.
This is a,
there's a lot of places to
work out and fuck around here,
but that's the big leap that happens I
think as a comic when you started being a
headline or you get to go longer when
you get to go longer and you sort of
understand pacing too. Like
even instinctually, like you
do a set and you're like,
maybe that one was a little off because
I did a little too much of this and not
enough of that and I need to like go high
and then bring it down a little bit in
two hours, two hours have to get off
of been doing this joke again. Yeah.
And then you start looking at your
notes and going over your shit and
rearranging things and then you
have a new idea pops in your head.
It's like everything else, so as a segue
works really well. It's like, oh yeah.
It's like everything else.
The more focus you put on it,
the more results the results are. That's
why Lamar Odom is fucking terrible now.
Tomorrow it all comes back
to you and Mario. Okay.
It all comes back to
the Kardashian family.
What are you going to have your special
come out when? 18th the 18th of December.
Nice. Yeah. The new website
is going live any day now.
It should be like either today or tomorrow
if you finished it. Yeah, it's done.
Cheesy, cheesy. I didn't
have to edit much.
It was almost all the first
show in Atlanta, the first show.
I got everything the way I want it to
accept like a couple of taglines that I
stuck in from the second show. It
was really easy. It was easy. Yeah.
There was a couple, a couple of lines
that I forgot in the first show,
but it was such a great crowd was so fun.
We wanted to take those lines that
you've forgotten victims fitting back in
there. It's just don't lose them
forever. I had to put them in there.
There'll be gone because they forgot
library. Yeah, they would be gone forever.
They were really good lines and a, they
don't fit anywhere else. Not Right.
They're a joke.
It's just pertaining to that one subject.
I can't go back to that side of
[inaudible] would like to wear. Yeah,
it was easy because I did the same bid
and the second show so I just took part
of it and I I it was only twice
on two. Uh, two different.
You got sidetracked in your mind
sometimes when you're like talking like,
oh look, a normal human. Yeah, fuck goes.
And he dropped the next two sentences
you were going to say, yeah,
that and you and I have similar styles
in that we're not very structured on
stage. We fuck around a lot and
then leave ourselves room to ad Lib.
And I do that even when I record special
and you forget to go back to. Yeah.
So I do all of a sudden he sold to like
try a little more to do just to get
through it. Word for word. I would
think so but no, not the last.
That special that I did in Atlanta was
the first time that I was ever on stage
or even though it was filming a special,
it was exactly like I was having
a comedy shows having a set.
Yeah you did everything the same.
You know it wasn't like all right look
I have to do this sober because this is
fuck that. Pass it, pass it. It's
do this. We you know had the,
I had a beer,
I think I had a glass of wine.
There was that guy who snuck into
the green room, brought his own beer,
remember that ship Ryan
really weird and he just
snuck in ahead like,
like somehow like I'm your man with a
beard for Joe Rogan. Local beer maker.
Wanted to just wanted to get me his beer,
bullshitted his way into the green room.
Cool guy with like that
seemed like a nice guy.
I'm going to thank him on the
CD cover early for the beer.
You can drink the beer. Drank his beer.
Nice guy. I thought it was a ballsy move.
Not that I'm encouraging it.
You fuck stop it.
Enough of that bullshit my way
into places. I'm sure he did.
That whole Trent Reznor thing's hilarious.
The most embarrassing thing.
One time I got my self like back into the
green room about Wayne Concert and uh,
I wasn't supposed to be back there and I
was with this girl and I was just like,
we came in and were like,
hey guys, what's up?
And they booked all just like looked over.
I think they were doing something bad
or something like that. They were like,
okay, get out. And then I'm like, so they
left you there. I just asked you that.
Have some cool thing they
do with the Internet. Like
you're allowed to use their,
their songs for like pretty much
anything [inaudible] now. Yeah.
They have all the songs on
loop nonstop from Pandora
before that time. But yeah,
you're allowed like use them
for things too. They're like, let people
use their songs. Really. I know. I, I'd,
I'd heard something like that.
Like they let go ahead.
Like it's put it in a rap song and do
whatever the fuck you want. That song.
Hash pipe. That's a bad ass on hash.
I know that reserve version of it. Oh,
pull. Pull it up Brian. See if he
could pull it out. Wean Hash Pipe.
It's fucking great song. Yeah, it's
my favorite Wayne Song. Really? Yeah.
Yeah, yeah. I can't believe you've
never heard it. I never really got that.
You have, you're talking about
Weezer. Oh, did I say ween? Yeah.
Weezer yeah, it's a totally different
game. Wrote that song. Yeah.
That's a totally different band band.
Well they should sue because I got
confused. So shows whoever was first.
Wayne broke up now. So it's all
these weeds are still together. Yeah.
That's all I got for it. Do it. Well
guess what? We use better hash pipe songs.
The Shit I loved. Weezer
man, is this it? Yeah.
And cleaning kit. The commercials. Oh God.
Commercials. You know what's gross man?
I've been reading websites lately.
I don't want to name any names,
but in the middle of reading,
the website,
commercial will pop up and you
have to click add, so disrupts you.
Oh, how dare you. You fuck
heads. Plus when you're high,
if you get your concentration interrupted,
but you've got to make a whole trip.
Yeah. Jesus fucking Christ,
man. Why you remixed thing this?
Just play it. Play it. Play it right
little.
I feel the need to remix shit. That's a
great band. It's a great fucking song.
That's a great God damn song. It's
still, you're mixing it. The Echo,
the echo that stuck second
said no, I know you.
Are you ever go play laser tag?
Yeah.
I miss playing laser tag tag in
Los Angeles. I want you to go,
go do it. Like some ultimate lazy.
You would be surprised at how, uh,
how much your stamina has dropped since
the last time you played laser tag laser.
You'll do one role. I'd be like, you know,
it's pretty fucking bad ass shooting.
I went to [inaudible].
I suck at it though. I only hit two of
them ever. I hit one out of 20 shot.
He gets 13 times. He got like six.
He's really great angel. That pig.
I've changed my opinion. Oh yeah.
Music was amazing. It's true, man.
He's just ripping Pega Pars, ripping it
up. Oh, you guys on, you're talking about,
you're talking about is his birthday. He
had roast a pig roast. It's an animal.
That's good. He's a good dude, man. I love
that guy. Anyway, he uh, his show, um,
trip flip. Is that what's
called a yeah. Yeah. Try it.
It should be the [inaudible] podcast
finally went up, finally went up.
Forecast. Forecast. Yeah. So I
was on his show the other day.
I just showed up at this gun range.
She called me to go really fluffy people.
They're like, he has, he takes
people and takes them on a tour.
He took him on a tour, La and one of
the things they wanted to do was like,
do some stuff with different people that
they liked. And it was so Burt said,
do you want to shoot skeet?
Shoot with me.
So it was me and these people
against Burt and I think Birdie,
they're tied us or beat us.
All of our scores together.
We were with three of us were putting
that. He just knows how to do it. Yeah.
I never shot a shotgun before at like
those moving claims you have to run with
it. It's just, I saw it. He did it.
He never did it either and he was
pretty good at it really. But man,
how good does it feel? Warm blows up.
It's awesome. I only happened twice.
It's 13 times in the fucking thing.
Keeps saying me go side to side or it
goes away. It goes all over the place.
It they just, you don't know where it's
going. You have this whole launch him.
Yeah, he, I'll pull and then you
try to like catch it with a shotgun.
It's fucking hard. Wow. It's hard. Yeah.
It's fun though. Really, really, really,
really fun. Yeah. Yeah. Sean Miller
like I used to with the cover,
but if he does it,
I mean Indianapolis.
I'm glad Burt finally put together a
podcast. I heard it. It's hilarious.
Of course. Of course it is.
He's such a great honorable,
you know when you would hear like shitty
things that happened to him or dudes
who were shitty to him.
I don't why I'm super protective of Bert.
I hear that kind of Shit.
I got actually get angry or very
license fucking nicest guy of all time.
He's a sweetie. What's that
again? We don't want to talk
about that. I don't know.
Need to dig up any old scars of
WHO's what? Shitty to Bert. Oh,
several people. Several,
several peach opic. Jesus. Fuck.
That's like first time I've ever
heard Brian saying drop the drama.
Just not being serious. Oh, it's
all just for for theater. Had you,
have you played this blade slayer game?
I've been playing it. That's good planet.
What does blade slinger kerosene games.
One of our new sponsors has this
a fucking sick game for the IPAD.
I pulling my iPad out of storage.
I stopped using my iPad because um,
uh, even though it's an awesome tool,
I would read books on it mostly.
And I went back to like just a regular
book reader because I found that if I
know that I can just stop
reading this book and go online.
I'll just go online and let us, let me
check my email real quick. And then Noah,
what Lincoln was this?
That someone's Sunday man.
And then the next thing you know, I'm
fucking, I'm not reading anymore. I'm,
I'm sitting in front of my
computer veggie now. Um,
so I'm going to pull it out of retirement
just to load up this fucking game.
Oh really? First scared. What's the game
called? It's called Blade slinger heads.
Who made, who's making it?
Our new sponsor. It's called
kerosene games. And uh,
they're, they're, they're starting to
make really sick gains directly. Yes.
But it's not, it's an iPad game only iPad.
Yes. They make an android coming sick.
High resolution games only for the
IPAD or the computer? No, no, no.
I think we're computer man.
They computer science. Good.
You want the touch controller?
Yeah, those are fun. Yeah,
like all those stupid
buttons and everything.
Like that's why like
Nintendos and all that shit.
That's those mother fuckers are on the
way out move shit like it starts with
cash generation. That's the, that's
the best way of interfacing. Yeah.
Know Poland triggers is fun.
Like actually pulling the trigger,
those video games where you pull out,
you have to plug the thing in offscreen
to reload. Those were fun games.
Zombie Games. Yeah. I love those.
Took that to the next level and had
like a three d virtual reality software
world you could go to.
They didn't intend to.
We has a new virtual virtually
no like no virtual glasses.
Will you think you're in that world and
actually shooting zombies was going to
go that way, right? Yeah.
They must be close to that.
I think something happened and like the
visuals were stalled out for a long.
Dave and Buster's had something click
close but you didn't really feel like you
were there but you sorted it.
I don't remember that one that much,
but I know I remember something
about that like they had,
they had tried it but it sucked the
fat one. It just wasn't that good.
I want it to be like inception where you
just fucking go, you can kill anybody,
but if you get killed, boom, you're
awake, you're out, you know. Ah,
that's possible. Why wouldn't
it be possible? You really
feel like you're there.
Will you remember in inception when he
realized at the end that he was still in
it? Spoiler alert, Euler. He didn't
realize, he didn't realize it,
but we realized,
we realized that there was care anymore.
Some fuckery afoot perhaps
locked in a alternate reality.
The debts.
That would be the coolest
way to experience a video
game for sure it would be,
but I feel like they had that
in the x files and it like,
it would go bad of course like someone
would get killed in the virtual world.
If you had a feel game inside,
you were like the,
like the scoring was inside
your body. Explain like, like,
like you'd look up and you'd
see the score inside your,
your eyes feel like if you
fucking get hit with feel
it. Yeah. Driving game.
We sick too and you could just see
like you're looking at the inside of a
windshield or have your score up there.
Virtual reality,
airplane simulators, flight
simulations, those are big early on.
Airplane simulators.
Well they use them for training.
They still use it for training pilots.
And so is that why the nerds liked it?
Cause I could feel like army people.
Yeah. Well also, you know it's,
it's how they train people to handle
like how a plane really reacts.
Like they can get it pretty
close. I never, I was like,
you don't kill anybody in
these things. No, you don't
shoot anything. No, no, no, no,
no. Check out this iPad game. All right.
This is about flying around. Look at it.
This is the game.
Like wow,
the graphics are fucking
slow to avoid that guy.
And this is like,
you know,
you're in an airport or something
somewhere and you want to waste some time.
You will run out of batteries
planning this motherfucker.
The cool thing about it is that
decided to make these things,
uh,
have you played that game and
just see the preview. Yeah.
I've been playing this since
Beta. It's really good. Fine.
Okay, well I'll ask. It's like one
of those games like, I don't know.
Have you ever done where you
like you swipe left and right,
like, you know, attack them? Whenever
I look at video games that yeah. Okay.
I feel like I'm a heroin
addict. That's like, it just,
I just always know there's going to be
a day when I'm gonna come back. Oh yeah.
You're a junkie. It's like, it's
like a heroin addict to say, listen,
I'm going to not do heroin
for at least five years,
but there's going to be one day where
I'm going to put on some fucking pink
Floyd. That's what alcoholics do. They
still say they're alcoholics. Get back to,
is the new trapped in the closet,
do you know?
No.
It's up to chapter 32
32 it's r Kelly ended up in class.
You don't even know their videos
trapped in the closet.
How was the wait in the car?
This is real damn bird.
That's what's act it out.
Hold that deal with this
shit on you this time.
Oh my God.
You keep your hands until you try it.
I would love to see you be our sniper.
I was trying to turn up the volume.
Go with the whole,
you can't bullshit me. Don't see
him. I asked him so can't even see
that cop diamonds hanging around our
Achilles Nick Mario Brothers game.
He's got like this crazy bold some shit.
Yeah.
Wow. What is this? It's so, he's like
sort of making it a priority to himself.
What's he that guy? He was like a
soul. There was never a pip guy.
Yeah,
it's a different guy.
Okay.
This is don the magic wand.
The bar.
A few racks in a place like this
isn't even a real song though.
Check out all 32 GS.
Well it started out how many
hits they have, his holdings,
it's trapped in the closet.
Started out as a music video that became
this sort of like a musical that became
a DVD and I bought it and I've sat
there and wash it with mouth agape,
like just horrible. It's unbelievably,
but it's not just horrible,
but it's like what's it's, it's
insanity. It's like complete insanity.
But it's so insane that
it becomes really good.
It becomes entertaining
because it's so crazy.
Yeah,
man.
I like that one song.
What was the song that we kept
playing over and over again?
MMM.
Cherish should love the art Kelly Song.
You know,
behind the scenes. Yeah.
Uh, trapping the trap. No,
wasn't trapped in the closet.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It was behind the scenes.
Oh my God.
I can't believe I can't remember
it because we played it so much.
I told you we need to start
putting the Alpha brain interim.
It was so well I picture it
wasn't trapped in the closet man.
It wasn't, no, no, no, no,
no. It was one where he got in
a fight with his girlfriend.
Remember that's trapped in the closet.
Like number one you have no, no,
no in the closet because you know,
like has it can get trapped in the closet
was like he was having an affair and
she was having an affair and he was,
this guy was gay.
There's a lot of shit going on.
This isn't supposed to be about him.
Well you going, are you going to go pee
again? Because the little child, go ahead.
Go Pee coke addiction.
Someone in the on Twitter,
I'm sure knows if you're
listening on Twitter.
Let me know what the fuck
video I'm talking about.
I can't believe I can't remember the,
um,
it was a spectacular
video, you know, I mean,
I'm just going to watch it.
Bitch. I wish you would burn
my mother fucking clothes.
Maybe that we'll talk
real talk. Real talk with
Art Kelly Dude. That,
that is one of the all time great
unintentional pieces of comedy. Real talk.
Yeah. I always thought they
were the same for some reason.
No way we'll talk is way better.
Archives of bad mother. Yeah.
Pull up real talk and we'll
plant when Ari comes back.
So I don't feel like such a fucking
fool. I could not remember it. Uh,
it was one of my favorite things,
but the problem was I watched it so
many times that I actually had to like
promise myself I wasn't going to watch
it anymore because I was watching it like
once every couple of days and it was
like I was wasting big chunks of my time
and then I would shut it off like two
minutes in going, what am I doing?
Why am I still watching this?
Hmm.
Because it's so hard to tell if he's
being serious or if it's a parody because
it's so good.
So
because I think it's a great song,
you know what I'm saying?
Even though it's a lot of profanity in it,
but the profanity represents,
this is just how real real when
you argued with your girl and Shit,
you know what I'm saying?
So I did it on Youtube,
but I'm going to do to see if
y'all on youtube. No, hold on.
I gotta get me a drink to take me a shot.
Calls me back the stone. He's
jumping off here. So be real message.
I'm just going to be real. We just don't
roll with them. And we're going to do it.
I'm doing this for the fans that I know.
We'll talk.
Wait a minute.
Calm down.
I was at a club,
man.
No one
girl. I'm not about to sit up
here and argue with you about.
We'll talk seeker. Only thing I'm
trying to establish with Jews,
not who's right,
right here.
Just because your friends say she
saw me at a club with some model
small getting intrigue and he kick and
knee. This is my best person to say that.
We'll all the guys there. Did she
stay? There were other guys there.
Well,
the other guy's day will tell me this.
How the fuck she know I was with the
mother when the whole, wait a minute,
let me finish what I've got to say.
Fucking girl Kelly Kelly talk.
I want to see this explanation.
That's r Kelly.
So what was his reason for being there?
But we're just going to say to you,
we,
you would have to listen to the whole
thing and I don't think we're allowed to
play the whole thing, but it's a, it's
fucking a work of art. That's a real talk.
Thompson girl always talks about real
talk. Yeah. It's brilliant. Oh Man.
Our Kelly's just weird guy where it's
like, everything he does is kind of funny,
but I don't, I'm not sure if he's trying
to be funny, but when you watch that,
he was definitely trying to be funny.
That trapped in the closet.
Like he was like, he was milking it for
everything. I mean, real talk. Yeah.
He had crazy glasses are pimp
outfit. Yeah. Okay. He was
trying to be funny there.
Yeah. So we'll, yeah, yeah.
Art To be a character. Yeah.
But so what does he doing?
Sometimes he's trying to be funny.
Sometimes he's not cruise us.
They were talking about him. Like,
what is it crazy? I think it's crazy.
I think it's crazy. The, uh, access TV,
I think it was maybe had one
of his concerts on, yeah.
He was like, this is like,
he's single now. And this one is for the
ladies, you know, and you know, anything,
any ad this, uh, this advertisement.
I was excited. I'm like,
I want to see this concert.
Yeah.
I want to see this craziness that
this guy's putting out. Lizzy Dylan,
he might've fucked too many women.
I might've gone crazy with it. Yeah. Well,
could you imagine the volume
of crazy pussy that r Kelly,
how's going his way?
Just the volume.
The sheer volume of if you ever seen
him in concert and seeing those girls go
crazy for him. No. Oh, there
we go. No significant. Yeah.
Oh my God. They just scream and
lose their mind. Sane. Insane.
They're going nuts.
Wow.
There's thousands of them and they're
all women and they're going to bananas.
There's like four gay guys in the crowd
and that's it.
The rest is women, women, men
on dates and shit. You know,
and some dudes you can respect real talk,
but for the most part,
a lot of crazy bitches did that.
Is that whole sleeve more?
Mostly knew this one. Yeah.
That's like three years old.
I don't remember the flower with a stripe
down the middle of it. Oh, the, um,
like up a little cherry blossom.
Yeah, that's right here. Yeah. Yeah.
That's been there. I got to go
back to them. Thank you very much,
Darren Dellavedova from girl Tattoo.
It's not done yet. It's not finished.
I love following him on Facebook because
every like every day or so he'll post
like new photos of work he he's
doing are doing right now and it's just
so cool to look at his art every day.
Sometimes he puts a button at the insight.
Brian,
well he doesn't do,
but we should do clarify.
He doesn't do like dragons on
your Dick or anything freaky.
So if you're one of those markets,
if he's showing you it's because he like
tattooed a cheek or something like that.
Okay. It's not like the actual
butthole, like excellent.
My favorite [inaudible] I need to get my
tattoo fucking done cats and she would
get, she said she'd do it.
She was probably lying. Yeah,
she probably wasn't that long ago.
I'm sure she wasn't.
It's probably a matter of right down,
but then it's like not through it.
If they don't call me. Yeah,
I'd rather not spend 20 hours.
I think she would do it.
It just,
you might want to like see if he could
get the old one laser the little first.
So it's just not like, yeah, because if
he want to get something there, you know,
if you want to get a tattoo there right
now, you've got this big spot there.
Where are you going to have some anchor
that you don't want the other arm?
Let's see. Get, have an idea of
what you want to do with that area.
The desk squad cat around that in the
circle could actually be where the,
the uh thing though. Just have
that clock. The clock would be one.
I have the oh yeah.
The only problem is it'd be really hard.
It's like got to have white
ink over the uh, the red.
It's going to be a black one with
a white mustache. No, no, no.
The what is the circle? They're
like, what's the Red Circle? Oh,
that's going to be the
clock and I'll just keep,
just keep that old time face
looking thing like an antique,
you know what I'm saying to you?
You want to keep it,
you want it to be a red face.
The clock? Yeah. Why not?
Instead of holding the class holding
the cat is holding your original tattoo.
Cool. That's, that'll last.
We'll also have like a story for her
and you'll feel good that you took this
thing that sucked. It made it
better. You recycled? Yeah. Yeah.
It'll look cool if it's a little worn
down to deal when dudes from random place
to start getting that tattooed on my
body. That's a super hard, super hard.
Super hard with a finger up your butt.
What does that even Ari soundbite.
That's of my album and that's the
one that's available right now.
That's only been for sale for like
how long? A couple of months now.
It was number one. The 25th yeah.
Number one. Number one iTunes.
And then from that you've
already got a whole new hour.
That's pretty fuckin industrious
young man. Yeah, but it's been like,
it's been like 14 months when
it would've recorded. Right.
When Aubrey called you and told you
that he liked what I was doing in Texas,
that was like three months ago. And that's
all. It was all new. That's awesome man.
Yeah, it feels, yeah, it feels kind
of cool. You're doing the same shit.
You're writing so much now.
Yeah.
I think it's just a matter
of working out that muscle.
It's definitely got better at
it. It's definitely that. Um,
I think podcasts help too, man. Work
your mind. You mean it helps everything.
It helps expand your subject.
Yeah.
So many things that we talk about on
the podcast that they become like,
or a new stories or whatever.
That becomes super interesting also,
especially on this podcast. He talked
to a lot of interesting weird people.
So you gain perspective. Oh yeah.
That more than you would've before.
Getting firsthand like talk to them
where you can actually, you know,
understand things. Yeah. And it's
a bigger well to draw from sh yeah.
And we're getting new
people all the time too.
Like this chick that we had yesterday,
Cara Santa Maria,
she was fucking brilliant man and really,
really smart and but
like really interesting.
Take something like very hard liner.
Hard line for science pro
GMO plants. Pro Gmo. Yeah.
Pro Genetically Modified Foods.
Saying there's no evidence that it's,
it's bad pro pharmaceutical companies
because they produce good things like
antidepressants and anti chemical anti
alliance thing that goes a little too far
sometimes aren't terrible
aspirins. Awesome. She,
but she was a very sensitive person and
that's what would the interesting thing
was that she was just very sensitive
person who has this sort of hard line like
defense when it comes to science.
But then other than that,
she was like talking about like,
she would never hurt a person if someone's
coming to attack or she thinks she
would just not defend herself.
Oh really? Yeah. Yeah.
I found that really fascinating. I'm
like, that's, that's, that's really,
it's really interesting
that uh, people like, um,
that they think about things completely
alien and different than the way you
would,
or I would or I am fascinated
by different people's ways of,
uh, of navigating life, especially
smart people. You know, how they,
how they look at the whole thing. Like
there's a lot, like I make fun of Vegans,
but there's a lot to being a Vegan that
seems to me to represent someone is
trying to rise above the most ruthless
aspects of being a human being.
That consumption of other living
animals when they come down to like,
it's unlike the cruelty to animals and
looking nothing to argue with there. Yeah.
No way that you can't overlook.
So for my enjoyment for this animal
cruelty is a sign of human cruelty.
It's a sign of accepted depravity.
Like you can get away with it because
you're not doing it to a person. Yeah.
But this is the same muscle that makes
you stab a dog over and over again with a
pencil that'll make you do
that to a person you're,
you're a sick fuck or something
wrong with you. You know?
And I think the idea of being a Vegan,
and I was like a really,
I think it's a very powerful idea. Yeah.
I see where they're all coming from.
Is that like eventually we have
to address the fact that we're,
we're not going to stay
the way we are now.
Just like we didn't stay the way
we were when our great, great,
great ancestors were single
celled organisms. You know,
the idea is that life started out as
single cell organisms and wasn't like
monkeys just fell out
of trees. Okay. They,
they'd had to develop to
get to that point. Well,
if that's the case and we look at
where human beings are right now,
we will look at this sort of new
sentiment that we want to take care of the
earth. We want to be green, we want to,
we want to not eat meat and we want to,
you know, be kind to be vegetarians.
Like it seems like that that is the way
that they believe that human being will
evolve. It will evolve. Yeah. If you
led to look at, if you had extrapolate,
if you are completely objective,
if you weren't a person at all and you had
to say, well, how do you think they're,
what, what? There's also,
there's different possibilities of how
we could fuck it up and go the wrong way,
but if we weren't going to move forward
and become really kind of passionate,
what do we look up to him? Characteristics
of person. Yeah, and if you,
if you did create an
entirely vegan culture,
you would have most likely a much
more friendly openminded kind culture.
If no one was killing animals,
it sounds fucked up because you've
got way more shit done. Yeah.
You're just focused on
learning and producing things
and I think you would have
way less do shit.
I mean,
it sounds like a silly thing
to say because I'm not a
Vegan and I love meat and
I'm total hypocrite here, but I'm just
saying, I'm not looking at it as a me.
I'm looking at it as a PR on
the mind. Yeah. I'm, I'm a,
I'm a mind observing an organism.
I could see how we could go totally
the wrong way and some wacky dude in
Pakistan could decide to blow up some
wacky dude in India and then shit gets
crazy.
I could see that happen and I could see
someone in some part of the world that
really needs a hug,
just completely fucking up everything
cause no one's to prepared for.
Or I could see it man, if, if nine 11
could have happened and it did happen.
So we know it could have happened.
If something like that can happen,
other crazy shit can happen.
And I know that people are working hard
to stop other crazy shit from happening,
but the people working just to
make it happen. Yeah. So you can't,
oh well this and this is not necessarily
the way the human race is going to go.
Like the human race might just fuck itself
up, but if it doesn't fuck itself up,
you got to think that that is one
option for elevating the consciousness.
Like getting to a point where we
no longer need to kill anything.
The problem with that as predators,
I mean they have Nile
crocodiles now in Florida,
that's a new new threat or started
killing them. They have, yeah,
they have a kill on site or the
Nile crocodiles. But now, I mean,
look at how big the
fucking everglades are.
So you've got to go through the everglades
and you've got to find the forest
rangers. Yeah. And they have to have
guns and just look for these crocodiles.
And so far they haven't established a
breeding population that they know off,
but they are fine to start breeding them.
It's fucked. It's out of control. Fucked.
We're fucked. If they start breeding
were there, people are going to die.
Dogs are going to die.
Alligators are going to die.
They go kill, kill alligators.
Like Nile crocodiles are enormous
and they're super aggressive.
They can be 20 plus feet long.
Whoa. Yeah. They're fucking huge.
I think the world record was more
than 20 feet long. I think there's a,
there's a picture of a Nile crocodile
in, um, in, uh, uh, I think it's,
these are from Egypt at that area.
It's Thailand or somewhere that they
killed one of the largest crocodiles ever.
See if you could pull that up,
Brian.
It's like if you look up
largest crocodile ever, dude,
there are giant and they're super,
super aggressive and this one crocodile
is responsible for the death of many
villagers.
Really.
They were very excited when they track
this fucking thing down and killed it.
There are normal, yeah. The,
I mean we can't even ratchet
that up back underwater.
You can't get them no way that they
can go under water for hours. Yeah.
They don't even have to pop up. They
did. They don't have to breathe.
They can just stop their hearts.
Basically.
They dropped their heart
rate to like almost nothing,
but they kind of just has their
eyes out the out the water. Yeah.
And there's a way to have long snouts
the difference between them and the,
uh, the American alligator is big and
a lot of people wanted to protect the
alligator because alligators to a lot
of people represented like some unique
species that we just were lucky to
be around and take a look at them.
And for the most part, they're
fairly harmless. It's good.
You'd see him on a golf course.
It fairly harmless,
but they don't fucking kill people every
now and then too, man. They kill dogs,
you know, they, they
fuck up. And you know,
one guy was running from
the cops in Florida and he,
he ditched his car and jumped into the
water and as he jumped in the water,
the alligators attack them and ate them
right in front of the cops. Whoa. Yeah.
They just fucking ripped him apart.
They were right there.
I think he just jumped and where he
jumped, there was alligators right there.
So as he hit the ground, I mean, they
might've done it just to like for defense,
like what's he mean? He, he just
fucking pick the wrong spot to land.
And the alligators took 'em out right
in front of the cops. He was like, oh,
like I think he stole a car
or something like that. Yeah.
So obliterated him right
in front of the cops.
Like in Indiana Jones when the
guy falls. Yeah. Wow. Well,
crocodiles will hunt you.
That's the difference. What
does that mean? That's one,
but that's not the one
largest crocodile killed.
It's actual live crocodile skin. Where's
that? That doesn't look like nothing.
Go to go to Google images and they
have less people. They captured it.
What does the second one look at? The
size of that fucking thing. That's real,
but that's an alligator, I
believe. Is there a crocodile?
How many feet is it? Oh,
21 point 21 foot crocodile cheese.
It's Christ,
but that doesn't look like nothing
compared to the one with the villagers.
Just look up giant crock villagers on
Google images and you'll see this insane
fucking picture. It's these
people have it all like tied up.
I don't even know if it's dead yet.
Yeah.
And then what? It's just
massive. I can't wait to see it.
Okay.
Yeah, that's it. Look at
the size of that thing.
These people were all gathered around
this. There's several pictures of it.
That's just one that got shot. The grown
adult wing spanning it. Oh yeah, yeah,
yeah. Wow. They're huge
man. They're huge. Wow.
He's barely on a little part of his back,
by the way.
All the people in these pictures
are so black. Yeah, I think there.
That's the Philippines, I
think. Oh really? Yeah. I did
a bit of exposure on that.
I can't,
I'm not sure that this thing is massive.
There's a lot of places in the
world where if you live there, man,
you got to worry about sure. Much
meet with that provider. Those people,
I don't think they eat them. What? I
think they just fucking, I don't think,
what do you mean that the tiles?
I don't think he crocodiles easy.
That one right there,
Brian. Right above your cursor. Click
on that. No, no, no. The other ones.
Okay.
That one. Yeah. Click on that one.
Look at the size of that thing.
Wow. It's on a damn.
Well, look at his legs.
His legs are bigger than those people.
Yeah. The clock and I is bigger.
The people fight over and look
at the guy right over the middle.
There's a perspective issue because
we're not sure how far those people were
from way back. They could be back a little
bit to make the photo more impressive.
That's most likely how it is.
Because if you look at the left
hand side where the mouth is open,
those people don't look like
they're under the mouth.
So if they're the same
size as those other people,
that means they're all behind it and
it makes it look more impressive,
but it is fucking huge. Whatever
it is. Okay. By the way,
those were around when dinosaurs were,
those are essentially living remnants
of the Jurassic. They get out of it.
They just lived there just so bad
ass. They survive, survive the plate.
They probably ate everybody that died.
You know, alligators could eat anything.
Crocodiles can eat anything. They
eat license plates. So eat your foot.
We don't give a fuck. So the, the
idea is that if they did that,
if they just could eat anything, we've
got no animals out here. Really? Huh?
Or coyotes I guess. Okay. Mountain lions,
ma'am. Oh yeah. Out here. Those are,
those are legit. Yeah. I've been at,
uh, fascinated by Alaska shows. Man.
That's all I've been. Really. Yeah. All
I've been watching lately is Alaska shows.
I had a meeting recently
yet a discovery channel.
And we were talking about this show and
one of talking about Alaska show us for
like 10 minutes last cause awesome.
I'm obsessed with these Alaska shows.
What are the Alaska,
they're subsistence shows.
It's all punched survive in
Alaska. Yeah. Living in Alaska.
And most of them they uh,
they hunt,
they catch fish and they smoke the fish.
They grow their own vegetables and uh,
they, you know, they have to fix
their Alaska, the wilderness. Oh Dude,
you just showed me this creek. They're
like, look at that creek. It's beautiful.
Like summertime's picturesque and it's
flowing down this mountain. She goes,
if you drank from that,
you'll get immediate medical attention
and you'll die within a day and a half.
Wow.
Like Montezuma's revenge
was just everything of his
shit and you can't stop it.
Lie what's in it? Badger Shit.
Whoa. Something like that.
Badger droppings and it makes it
completely, he said it tastes the same.
Oh my God. Probably wasn't a day and
I probably like a few days, but like,
oh my God. Yeah. That's
terrifying. Badger Shit. Yeah,
that's all.
It's just a little bag of shit in there.
And it makes it still tastes refreshing.
Quenches your thirst.
You have to know about that stuff if you
go live there, right. Fuck yeah you do.
Yeah. Fuck yeah. You did like
water. Okay. I'll put it in a glass.
I could see right through it. Yeah. Good
badge or shit terminated. These shows.
They um,
like one of them,
a guy died well while filming himself
while they were filming him, he died.
He, while they're filming his village, he
was like one of the guys in the village,
he fell. He uh, they take the snowmobiles
out and they try, they crossed the river.
The river is frozen,
but sometimes they fall through into the
river and you're fucked. Fucking that.
Yeah, because you're, you're going with
the current, like the, when you pole, you
don't stay put you, you start going
down river and you're under the,
you're going to have to swim your way
back to the hole and get back up all while
you're freezing and your muster
shutting down. Cause they're all still,
everything's shutting down.
You can't breathe.
You can't believe how much it constricts
your body's ability to utilize oxygen.
It's like immediate, like the cold
water. It's like a constrictor.
Everything tightens up. It's very
hard to survive. Amazed by that shit.
When you talk about your body and in
terms of like a machine or it just,
it does it to this and we can't
process oxygen. If you're too cold,
that's what it is. Your body shuts down.
This is terrible feeling. We can't your,
your lungs like clamp down and even
though you're holding your breath like
you're fucked, you're like, oh my God,
I can't do this very long. Oh yeah.
There's all the oxygen
that you're holding onto.
It's going out of your system rapidly.
You can break the ice because
every time you break it,
you're going to have to just go, you're
not going to break the ice, you know?
No Way. No Way. You're going to
have to get back to that whole,
you're going to have to get out
of your time to start spotting.
He's not coming back. Wow. That's
what happens to those guys. Yeah.
Some guys on the show had told similar
stories and said that they survived.
It's wait who died on the show? One of
the guys that was in [inaudible]. Yeah,
he was on the jet ski
or Snowmobile and uh,
he was doing this thing they do
when the ice is starting to thaw,
they take chances and they go
across the river. They have to like,
if they have like traps, did they
show that to show him, show him fall?
They weren't there. They
had, they showed them,
they showed everybody looking for him and
then everybody finding out that he was
dead. And then they
showed a, they have this,
what they do is they like life and
death is like so normal out there.
And these people,
they have like things that they do as a
community when someone dies because it
happened in ceremony. Ritual. Yeah.
It's called a potlatch and they, uh,
they're allowed to shoot a moose out of
season for this, this, uh, this ceremony.
Yeah. So this guy goes, yeah.
Even though it wasn't a hunting season
for Moose, he goes out, finds a moose,
shoots it, and that's like the law.
You're allowed to do that if someone dies.
And so they're getting back
and they cook Moose head soup.
That's like the big thing that they
do for this. How it's fascinating man.
And these people that live there,
I mean technically they're supposed to be,
that's supposed to be America technically,
but it's clearly not American wilderness.
It's,
it's absolutely cons that were there.
Yes.
It was all settled by people that were
like ex cons or running away from a
jealous boyfriend, shit like that.
Like I'll relocate to Alaska.
No one will find me or James Your name.
There's small towns that are in the middle
of nowhere that our homestead towns,
what does that mean?
It means that people came there and
some of them from other countries,
they came there and they said,
let's try to to make any,
you're like one of the guys,
I believe their,
their family was from Sweden and they
were worried about the Nazis taking over
the world.
So they left Europe 80 years ago,
went to this place in Alaska and
started this homestead and they,
you know when you homestead out there
they give you like a certain amount of
acres and like I think yeah,
I think they were offering like land
to people. If you could live on it.
And they were trying to like get
people to, to live in certain
areas and they, they did
that in Montana where, uh,
we're Brian Cowen,
I went hunting.
There's a lot of these
really old homestead sites.
We see these old broken
down frames of a house.
And it's so fascinating because like
you're walking around inside of this old
broken down house and like this is where
someone decided they were going to try
to live part of the wilderness. Yep.
And there's no roof on it anymore.
It's completely fallen apart and it's
probably 300 years old, you know? Yeah.
I mean it's old as fuck that
places a strange, strange place.
No repairs onto it. Oh No, there's
nothing there. Well, there's a difference.
So what happens is people died
out or they all left the left.
There's different states of disrespect,
disrepair.
There's some of them that looked like,
you know,
if you put a little money until you
could actually turn it into a little log
house. And there's other ones
that are just nothing left.
But you're worried they're going to
follow that up around around you? No, no.
The wind, the one that I stepped into,
there was nothing left on the roof.
There's no roof left. Oh. So it was just
like some boards and some, some, uh,
it was obviously made out of logs that
they had a sound Nazi house out here
somewhere. It's a hike to it, but
it's what these people went to.
It was like Americans like
left [inaudible] they assume
Hillary's going to win
really until they just went to wait until
it happens because they thought they
were gonna be too many reprisals. There's
like Nazi a lovers. Whoa. Until then,
so those, wait until Taylor takes
over and then eventually left.
And so where are they now?
They're all gone. I don't know.
They came back to America.
There's an Indian place near here.
It's an Indian house. I think they
use it for like weddings and shit.
Like it's like a big, nice,
beautiful place. It's got
swastikas all over it really?
Yeah. Yeah. And we talked about
this yesterday apparently.
Is that sticky? No, no, no.
Nothing to do with the Nazis. It used to
be, it's like an ancient Hindu symbol.
Oh yeah. Way, way, way, way back. I read
a book about what the swastika means.
Different cultures of good luck
and good things. Nazi's ruined it.
Plus they ruined that mustache option.
They've ruined it bad.
It's amazing that that,
that one shitty dude could ruin Jordan's
doing this stash option. Sort of.
He's got a little goatee
going on, so really? Yeah,
but it also shows his arrogance that
he was trying to pull off the Hitler.
I can't like the area cool anymore. Well,
it's like someone said to him like, man,
you can't pull off the Hitler.
It was like, motherfucker,
I can pull it might hit Jordan. I'm
like, well, why else would he want to?
He can't think that it looks good.
Anything you can do, I can do better.
People only thought that
looked good before photos.
Once photos came along and they
saw that mustache, they're like,
what the fuck am I doing?
Hitler?
That kind of the whole growth
further when and go further, judge,
see this shit your websites out? Oh, it's
up. So that's what it's all for sale.
This is all the new website. This
is my new website. Yeah, it's uh,
I got to send some videos to them,
but the meter put up here, there,
it was never really that. I see a lot
of people with your tee shirts at,
at my comedy shows. Yeah. A lot.
Cause Death Squad tee shirts.
There's tire primary t shirts.
He, the primary teachers who got
this new one, the best design ever
one that uh, Mike Maxwell did.
It's fucking awesome. I
had a vision inside my tank
really to be told him and he,
I told someone he recreated it to a t.
It's perfect.
It's a monkey or a chimp rather.
And he's got two open palms.
One Palm is a floating home on the
other palm. The word home. No, no, no.
I'm like an and ancient Tibetan writing.
The symbol of you ever seen the symbol
for home and the other hand has this um,
uh,
the atomic symbol,
the symbol for atomic energy and he's
got his mouth open and there's a mushroom
on his tongue and his third eyes got like,
like geometric designs coming off.
It looks dope.
Mike Maxwell [inaudible]
that one is a red,
red and black or a white and black.
But uh,
I like it's one of those, is that the
color of the Monitor? That's pink?
Is that your monitor?
You got your fucking no colors
all out of whack on your mind. Oh,
like he wasn't doing that.
But did you do that on purpose?
That would actually look cool and pink.
It's funny that one color became
like bad for completely color is not,
it's not like dolls or anything.
You could say we're like, no,
men just don't want to play with
those. It's a color, but like
yellow is probably more weak.
Like bright yellow is probably more
weak than, than pink, isn't it?
Like at least pink looks cool when
you mix it with black. It does.
I have picking my shirt.
What's wrong with pink?
Nothing should be wrong with it. Everybody
agreed. You know that pink layer,
we all agree that pink corvette chick that
lives around here that I see, it's uh,
there's this girl that lives
in Los Angeles is not a
girl or [inaudible] name is
Angelina superfood that you've seen
around here. Just kind of crazy.
And which she used to do crazy take
out billboards. Yeah. And no one knew.
I mean this is when I first moved here
in 94. She had been doing it for decades.
So when I moved I was like,
what is this? But go ahead.
Nobody understood what it was like when
you first come. Here you go, what is this?
When you see these billboards
and says Angelina on it,
it's her and she's very voluptuous.
She's like, uh, you know, in front of
a car or something like that, you know,
in her underwear. And then it
says like management call and uh,
you'll spot her around town
because she wears, you know,
she has a clothing paint,
white corvette and Angelina on the back.
And what's crazy is that I see
her all the time and it's like,
just shows you how small la is.
Even though it's big.
I see her all the time.
Yeah,
I've seen her at least 10 times over the
[inaudible] driving by the same people
a lot. You don't notice,
right? Yeah, no shit.
Cause I see her. Did you see her and
took a picture of her? Is this, you know,
this isn't me, but this is
a, she is old now. Oh yeah.
And she puts a picture of, she's running
for president. Right. Let me just hit it.
I was married.
I still hit it.
I mean if you weren't married
Jesus to say you hit the corvette,
I would break and she would die.
She would die for sure.
Do you want to go easy on her death?
You,
it wouldn't even know what you're
saying. The doors, the likes.
I really don't even know what you're
saying. All right. Would you hit that?
What'd you hit that? Yeah. All right.
We're looking at that picture. Yeah,
that's not what I know what
she looks like up close.
You would have to be on ketamine.
There's no way you would fuck that.
She be supplying the ketamine. She's
Jakey grandmother and I'm not joking.
I bet she's a nice lady,
but she's a,
she was old in 1990 when,
uh, when I first came here,
that was like this weird thing because
the photos didn't look anything like her.
What if she's done any video she had?
What's, how does she make her money?
She married a rich dude.
Yeah.
That's a fucking 20 years old and
she looks 90. There's her dude.
I bet that is her. Wow. Is that really
an old picture of her? Is that legit?
Maybe it's just a fucking road. I
think I was just a pink corvette. Oh,
okay. Yeah. I don't know what the
deal with her is, but uh, how bad,
she's a nice lady.
Someone's taking pictures with her
just with your thing.
Oh,
I see. I would, I mean, just for boobs
alone, I'd probably, okay though.
Imagine if that girl imagine.
Okay, the way. Move Up. Move Up.
That's your vagina coming out. Brian
started leaking out vagina. No,
go back down to catches. That's a vagina
coming out and down. No, that's, yes.
That's below the skirt line where
it's too close. Where it's happening.
Yeah. You know what? Have some respect
for this old lady. Why Zoom in our snatch?
He looks pretty cute. Yeah, but
this is not really what she looks
like. She's a nice old lady, I'm sure.
But you know the,
the the sexy image not aging gracefully.
Yeah. That's sexy. Image is, it becomes
a monstrous. That's what's weird.
It's amazing. Yeah. Like there she
is like look, this is like a really,
that's sounds like something,
he's an elderly lady.
That's what I was telling a joke or
were due to you make it look like that.
I look at his legs. That's nice legs for
an old lady. When her body looks great,
if she would cut down on
the silicone in her breasts.
She's proud to be a lot better luck than
oil that turn off the lights a little
like a certain look that
you can only pull off.
You know when you're so her rich
husband just lets her just wanting,
I don't pay for billboards. I'm just
making shit up husband. Why are you sad?
That's what I heard that tried to crash
that party. Does she make money off?
That was the rumor. The rumor was
that her husband had a, it was a,
but it's like she's like an la,
an La celebrity.
I can tell you where they live at.
Tito's Tacos like dentists were roof.
What are you talking about? Tito's
Tacos. It's another La commercial thing.
I have no idea what that is.
You love to hear those two key on there.
We're watching late night TV. You always
had cable, Huh? Yeah, I always had cable.
Tito's Tacos. Tito's Tacos.
He has key from Van Nuys.
I like Tito's Tacos for folks who
don't know what Brian's talking about.
That's like one of the most famous
places he's auto dealership.
When I was a kid in New York, it was
crazy. Eddie, do you remember crazy?
Eddie crazy? Eddie has prices
are insane. Crazy Gideon blog.
There's a bunch of crazy guys,
but crazy. Eddie was really,
his prices are insane and crazy.
Eddie wound up having to go to, um,
I think he went to Israel. That was
crazy. Gideon. Crazy. Eddie did too.
Dude or crazy and he went to
jail. Let's see. Cause he had,
he didn't benefit from being part of
the Jewish people so he couldn't leave.
And it was crazy Gideon from,
I thought he was in New York to here.
I know knowing of these crazy
guys I don't hang out with.
Well it was like they were the famous
guys back in the days that were selling
like, like TV's and shit.
That's how they got famous.
I always want you to pay cash.
Like there was a furniture company,
two brothers, um, in Boston
and they were the, uh,
they were like famous.
I remember somebody that,
one of my sister's friends because of
the commercial new one of the kids and it
was like a big deal. Like, Oh,
her dad is that guy from the
fucking furniture commercial.
And like everybody was all excited at
this dude from the furniture commercial
was a, you know, like his kid was
like in the neighborhood. Like what?
He's only on a commercial cause he
paid for commercial talk. Exactly.
But they became, yeah.
Okay. Founder of crazy.
Eddie gets eight years in prison
and big fine. Really? Yeah,
he's from,
uh,
he's actually from 1971
so it wasn't for what?
I think 1971. It's probably, he
probably predates crazy Gideon. Oh yeah.
Crazy. Gideon's around now. Oh yeah.
That's crazy. Gideon is a fucking hack.
Yeah. He probably sold everything from
crazy Yeti. He falsified the chains books.
He falsified the,
the businesses books and he fleed
the country to avoid prosecution.
Which one was this crazy.
Eddie at the prices are insane.
In November of 1987 crazy
Eddie stockholders took over
the chain and discovered
a $45 million inventory shortage.
What?
The chain never recovered.
That dude must have been [inaudible]
$45 million out of the company town.
Something.
God
never heard of it. You know, he didn't
play the, I don't want to hear it.
I don't want to hear him. Stop. Look at
this commercial though. That just the, uh,
Tito's Tacos class. Yeah.
It's the funniest shit ever
loose. I got a hot check.
He was that guy.
It's like Douche bags.
He's there just dated Culver city.
That's right.
They have the twin douchebag dudes.
What's that message?
Echo things out because it's more
relaxing now. It's so weird. Stupid stuff.
Doing that son of a bitch. It makes it
unique. So crazy. Gideon is like a new,
see what his deal was. Eddie flipped
as a where to Eddie fleet too.
He fleed to Jerusalem and
we did know cage good.
The own. I wonder if the
crazy getting was, it was a,
just a figment of the board's imagination.
Gideon's closed in downtown La.
Maybe just went out of business. Did he
die? I don't know. Trying to find out.
Does it give you on, I'll give you the
best prices. [inaudible] TV. I crazy.
How do you spell Gideon? Gee, I. D. E.
O. N. Yeah. That's how I spelled it.
Just as crazy Gideon's closed. It
doesn't say anything about him. Crazy.
Gideon is crazy. Oh, okay. He
went to jail for tax evasion.
That's hilarious. They always ask you
to only pay cash. That's hilarious.
And Gideon's a Jewish name. Yeah. He, uh,
he followed any of that God's footsteps
completely. Yeah, pretty much, man.
Wow.
Talking about blazing a trail.
Yeah.
Embraces insanity and turn
it on to an advertising ploy.
This is a real commercial that aired on
local television and Gideon is a role
model for us all. Uh, okay. I don't
know what they're trying to say.
It was trying to talk too
much about the video is yeah,
I don't know what the fuck that some,
some takes on this are saying that it
might be actually they're talking about
crazy Eddie.
Oh really?
Crazy. Eddie went to jail for um,
that wasn't tax evasion. What was he?
I believe the murder or please say
murder, please say no. No, no. Crazy.
Eddie was the one who stole
the 43 million or so high.
You don't remember shit we were talking
about. That was a four minute ago.
That was like at least a full minute.
I can tell you the same story three or
four times in a row before he got mad at
me right now.
It's a story about,
uh, okay. TMZ says he's out crazy.
Eddie TMZ has a crazy Gideon video.
How crazy is crazy Gideon
as he worth listening to?
Maybe he's looks sort of
Weirdo. No, probably not.
Legendary television salesmen.
Crazy Gideon is back and
still packing so much crazy.
He inspired a brand new, poorly
dressed, loud mouth pitch, man.
Huh? Let's not him. I don't know. I've
got Brian to be, as I say, guy new,
pitch them in to do it.
I don't understand what the fuck they're
saying and I'm not willing to click
their links. Sons of bitches. You
led me on a more electronic salesman.
Why don't even know their names.
Unsatisfied
buying. Why? Well,
because back in the day,
that was like a good way to get
someone to go to your place.
Can you make yourself a celebrities
on van eyes? Just that you know,
having something that was like a good
jingle. That shit's important. Oh yeah.
How many good jangles we should have a
jingle. Brian, what would our jingle be?
Oh God,
no. That's your jingle. You've
got, hold on. What's your
deal with the olive garden?
What's, where's this all come
from and make it a hit song? No.
Where does the thing, with the
exception of obsession with this play,
are you trying to question
and what you know is broken?
Why are you looking at the glass and
say in class, why are you broken?
Why are you doing that? You know,
that's just his thing, man. Yeah,
you got to accept to dude, Sarah came
out of nowhere. Black chicks. He's, look,
he's a mess obviously,
but that mess lends itself to
create things and that aren't funny.
But when you say them a million times,
they suddenly become funny. But why?
Why Olive Garden? Whatever.
Why not do you get,
it could be anything. It could be
anything. It could be converse. All stars,
converse, all stars could be the
number one sneaker for death squad.
We could all decide that converse
all stars or red talk about converse.
All stars constantly.
And this motherfucker will bring up Kai.
Did you get there and your converse
all stars. That's what he would do.
He would do that until my wife,
my head explode because he's crazy.
That's just crazy. Got his crazy.
You got your crazy. I got mine.
I ask why? Why s why Joey Diaz
gets mad about mayonnaise. Yeah.
Try try to give him ranch dressing,
you know, kick you in the dig.
I've seen so many of those t shirts at
that shows it's blue cheese with wings or
go fuck your mother.
He went and sold t shirts and said that
blue cheese like go fuck your mother
responsible for two of the greatest
quotes in human history. Fuck Shakespeare.
If you ain't high by two 8:02 PM,
go fuck yourself. I like that.
That where that comes from.
Just an overall feeling.
People looking at you negatively
and just turning around. No, fuck.
You die by two in the afternoon.
You're the file itself.
That olive garden's song is
actually a German band. Uh,
covered it and remade it and
sold it on a CD. All of Germany,
but funnel what?
Olive Garden's song that the Olive
Garden Song I wrote and then they read.
I didn't know you wrote an
olive oil. Yeah, it's huge.
I don't want to hear about it.
It's not huge right now.
Listen to the German stop it.
No [inaudible] little bit German
band singing about olive garden.
They recovered my song.
It's crazy. It's like all heavy
metal rock. Do you know the band?
Yeah, I think it. They ask permission to
sell the song and I'm like, Oh yeah, sure.
Totally bought us. Hilarious.
You can be like David,
you can hear me in it
when
you can hear the garden
here. Yeah. It's too hard to
say when he's saying,
but funnels the name German band.
I'm sure that guy is not crazy.
It's not like he has a real doll with
your face tape to it that he fucks
violently every night. Here's
what they look like. Look at this.
This is the band red band on,
but funnel these.
This is the band that does not look like.
I look at this guy on the right it
looks like. Wow. Well listen folks,
I'm sure your podcast fans, so I don't
want to be make it funny, too hard.
I love those guys, but I need you
guys to move on with your life.
Are Those real people? That's my funnel.
Does that thing not loose? Is that loose?
Ari?
[inaudible] this thing up here
won't be also wiggly on Ya.
What? 10 minutes? 10 minutes?
Well, this fucking podcast is overlays and
gentlemen. It's been a fun one. Wobbly.
Ben, tighten that shit down. So
on. You're driving me it all away.
You can't figure it out. You don't
know what the fuck is this one? Yeah,
that's what I said.
This podcast has been brought to you
by many things. Ladies and gentlemen.
Ari shaffir.com that's s h,
a f,
F I r, early ants in the background.
You know what? That is false.
That's Ari's old CD.
It's new, but it's old because
he's already taping a new one.
You fucking freaks and you should be
there. It's going to be in Brooklyn.
Flat out like, Hey guys,
that's not gonna help when, um, December
28th, December 28th. Where's it at again?
The knitting factory in
Brooklyn and Brooklyn.
And you get street credit for doing it
in Brooklyn. That went through my mind.
Street cred. I'm just looking for a
name. Yeah, that's a good way to do it.
You are a name now? No, no, no. I'm
looking for a name of it, what does it,
but on that subject,
it is kind of strange that you went from
being a guy who had a hard time getting
booked to a guy who's not just headlining
but selling out clubs all over the
place, all over the country and in
Canada. And it happened like of that,
the guy who worked with in
a, in Minnesota, it was like,
oh, it's good. You know,
you get booked somewhere. It's a future.
Like I hope it's not just some like, uh,
yeah, it's nice that you can draw
people. And I'm like, Oh yeah,
we're going to have to come. Yeah. Like
instantly you went from that terrible
spot where you can't get booked and you're
trying to take shitty gigs because you
need to work and you know, you really,
it's really unsatisfying.
It's like that I couldn't even take gigs.
There were no gigs to take tomatoes.
I was like,
I'll go for whatever the
little you want to pay me,
just let me perform at your place.
Yeah.
And it's all just because already really
kind of stuck to his guns with like the
kind of material that he likes
and that kind of material.
You fucking can't get on TV with
it. So it's, it's, it's hard.
It's hard for you to get those credits.
It's hard to get that my mind a while ago.
Yeah. It's almost like it's impossible.
It's,
it's,
and what people don't
understand is there's a real
stigma attached in the world
of standup comedy to like
dirty acts and dirty jokes.
It's like you're thought to be
like a lesser version of it.
Do you think it's because
you can't get onto these,
they have to justify why or why you
get around when it was, is that, yeah.
If you were trying to get on television,
like say if you were trying to do it
tonight, show set, but all your, yeah,
just jokes about cut farts. You're,
you're not going to get off. You can,
I mean you, you might be able
to kill at the, you know, the,
the Framingham Howard Johnson's know
whatever the fuck has a comedy residence
inn. Yeah. But what you're not
going to do is you're not going to get
on the tonight show would can't fart
jokes. So those guys all wanted
to get on a tonight show.
Everybody wanted to do what happened to
Steven Steven right before Steven riding
in. There's a great documentary on it by
this guy, France Sala Meta and it's um,
it's about, uh, Boston comedy and
it's um, dammit. I should, uh,
I should Google this friend's solemn Meta.
I forget the name of it,
but it's all about,
uh,
what is it about Boston and
how it changed how the scene,
how the scene change after Steven Wright
got on television because then the
value is placed on being able to do the
stuff that you'd get on TV. Yeah, exactly.
So they're a lot more like one
liner comics after that. Um, no,
it's like guys tried to clean it up a
lot because they saw that if he got on
some night show, he got success. Oh, I can
get on the tonight show. Yeah, success.
That was the,
that was the whatever the catalyst know
to success was you had to get on the
tonight show back then. So, uh, that's
what everybody was trying to do.
So when I started doing stand up,
it was already when people
had found out about the,
you know,
the possibility of becoming famous because
Steven Wright was famous like stint
when stand up. Sit Out. That's the name of
it. Steven Wright was, it's really good.
It's really good. It's
a brilliant piece. Um,
Steven Wright was the first guy to go
from the tonight show. Like he was huge.
All of a sudden, like he did, like they
saw him and they were like, Holy Shit.
Is this guy good?
And from being on television,
they're like completely
turned whatever it was.
It was Letterman or to the sign shop,
whatever it was.
They completely transformed
this guy's life.
And so all these other guys that
were in town, they saw that too.
And they definitely saw, started
doing comedy that leaned towards that.
The problem was like if you're
not doing that kind of comedy,
you don't have a lot of options because
that's all that's on television and
people think that it's clever because you
do have to think more because you have
to avoid certain areas and subjects,
but it's not more clever.
It's just less funny.
You know? Oftentimes the,
the idea that you're only doing this
because these corporations want you to,
that's not the way you would naturally
tell jokes if you want it to. Yeah,
exactly. The rules on you and
you're not doing what you would do.
I always loved that you did that,
man. You really never fucking,
and the one time you got to television,
you pulled you dick out.
They told you don't pull your dick
out and you're like, Yup, okay.
You just let me know where,
where am I standing?
The Andrew said it was
just don't get naked.
And then the light bulb went off
in my house and that was perfect.
It's perfect because it was
fun as a lot of it dirty.
I went further than I was because it was
funny and it's funny and you pull your
Dick out. What's funny and what's Your
Dick? What do they kind of let it,
let it come on and we really, well,
we were little children, man. We're,
we're little children.
A grown man can't pull his dick out.
Who were you watching this with?
If you're watching it with your wife,
are you truly offended by
this guy pulling his dick out?
You can't just laugh at that.
When it comes at midnight on a Friday
on an HBO and after Jim Norton's been
about trainees for an hour and a half
that you really freaking out because this
guy pulls his dick out. Dick cyst.
But I love the fact that you,
you stood up for logic, you
know, your entire career.
He never really gave in.
I'm telling you,
I saw you this one time at that I
thought voting place in Rhode Island.
It set it, set it free a little
bit with that guy was like,
do you remember that we,
we took a trip to chicken and then to
Rhode Island chicken. It was horrible.
Just horrible,
horrible people.
Um,
but the Rhode Island that we get out,
we're walking to this big yachting club
and he goes, just so you know, the,
the crowd's a little
more conservative here,
so you might wanna try to keep it clean
a little bit. And he didn't even get,
he just said like that's how far
he got. And you were just like, no.
And then just turn right back and kept
walking. Like, just get off me nat. Yeah.
No silly man. Whoever you are, I don't
know who you are, but you didn't,
you don't get to having creative
control over what goes on up there.
Those people, they don't see me.
I know what I'd do. Exactly. Yeah.
That's what it was. But it's like, oh,
you know what you're doing here. Yeah.
Silly Bitch. They, they
didn't really apply to you.
They didn't go to that show because they
didn't know what was going to happen.
They went to that show because they
knew what I was doing, getting offended.
So what, they live in a nice neighborhood.
I live in a nice neighborhood too.
So a blow job when they were in high
school and by the time [inaudible] we
almost had a time.
So that was going on.
By the time Diaz went
up the all the fucking,
they'll taboos have been
crushed like grapes anyway.
Like that guy had to like hope and
pray that I wasn't as dirty as Diaz.
Diaz didn't.
He didn't slow down either,
but we were blue balls
and you're like fuck you,
this is one night and Rhode Island,
listen dude,
we're going to go over here either way.
And it was great.
It was one of the most fun shows ever.
It was in an outside wall tent area.
So your um,
your,
your CD that people can still buy or
your comedy last comedy special that can
still buy it. It's on Amazon.
It's on iTunes for the Holocaust,
the Holocaust.
It's fucking hilarious.
And you could see him December 18th or
20th December 28th don't go December
eight.
So I'll go to seminary because then you'll
have to camp out for 10 days and that
was such a small place. Everybody
gets tickets. It's cheaper.
If you get them like a few, like
this pod cast is over. You Dirty Fox,
please.
If you're interested in brain nutrition,
go to [inaudible] dot com
and get your freak out.
Plus you can get kettlebells like those
one on the ground right in front of feet.
I sling those bitches, son.
Yeah, that's a manly as fuck.
I can't remember the battle. Ropes did
some battle rope. My man, Justin, Milos,
my new trainer took me through some
battle ropes workout this week.
I'm out of shape son. I got to get
another series shape. I'm working hard.
Me and are you this special
podcast? Friday. Okay.
What is it at the icehouse chronic
because a, it's a special mug.
We're going to talk
about his mushroom trip
sockets. Comics went took motion.
This is all going to come to that.
I wish you were coming with
me this weekend, man. It's
going to be fun. Seattle,
I'm in.
Got The Fox Fox a on the UFC on Fox.
The lightweight amazing file by
the way. Yes, no lightweight title.
Benson Henderson.
It's taken on Nate motherfucking Diaz
for the UFC lightweight championship.
There's a few good ones. There. Shogun
is fighting. Alexander Gustafson. Yeah,
that's the one I was really excited
about. Ooh, that's going to be fun.
And Bj Penn's fight, Roy McDonald.
It's a nasty card and it's free.
It's free on a, on regular Fox and it's
like, like title fights man. It's a,
it's one title fight and the other
fights are like big name fights.
Bj Penn and Roy McDonald is
going to be fucking bananas.
And Alexandra Gustafson is a
beast and he's taken on Shogun.
It's like his biggest high
profile opponent to date. And uh,
that's uh,
like this Gustafson kid is like one of
the best kids coming up right now at two
oh five. And shogun is like one of the
old guard when the greatest of all time.
But he's had some trouble, but
he's not, he's not been bad.
It's because he's lost some close ones.
Yeah. Well he's had tough, crazy fights.
The fight of the year against
Dan Henderson fight of the year.
I know it was unanimous, but
it was like, it was amazing.
And then the Brendan
verify was another crazy,
crazy fight that could have
been fighting this year.
That was a thousand st fight.
But that's a, that's how fox,
that's a Saturday night so everybody could
see that. Um, if you want to go to, um,
the, uh, the parlor live in
Seattle. Tough Shit bitches.
Cause that shit sold the fuck out.
But what is the sold out is the
Wiltern theater on December 21st,
2012 there's like a hundred, I believe
it's a hundred tickets left. So, um, yeah,
if you want in,
and he had been saving up your money.
You got to pull that trigger son,
because a, it's honey honey band.
Joey motherfucking Diaz. Doug, Stan,
hope me and aliens promising you the
aliens were going to Chicago in January.
Had the aliens might not be able to
see you, but they will be there. Yeah,
we're going to be in Chicago. When is it?
Do you know the date? January 25th is it?
Yeah, January 25th to Chicago. Um,
and that I think is just on sale.
Go to my Twitter.
I don't know what the fuck.
twitter.com forward slash Joe Rogan figure
it out bed. Just when we're walking,
we're walking into the
office and then in March, um,
do you want to come to
Columbus, Ohio? Yeah. That's
been a Watson. I'm back there.
Brian Redman and Ari Shaffir. See that's
how I book comedy. You dirty fucks.
I do it live on the air.
And that's march.
Second tickets just went on sale
yesterday. That special there. Yeah.
And thanks a lot. Uh, stand up live
for giving me the wrong password.
Making me look like an asshole at the
palace theater is fucking amazing.
Isn't it?
Like the nutcrackers that's like their
big theater in Columbus and a cracking
nuts while I'm, may I, you see what I'm
saying? So, yeah, I work with words.
Doesn't that make you want to come
see me? Apply my craft. We'll talk.
This fucking show is over.
Uh,
we as always love the fuck out of all
of you dirty bitches and we wish you
nothing but love and happiness. And
we will see you next week. We got a,
a lot of craziness next weekend cooking.
Uh,
the 16th I got Dennis Mckenna is a,
it's going to be hard. It was great.
Yeah. He's, he's fucking awesome man.
A honey honey band is going
to be here on the 17th.
We got a lot of shit happening,
dirty Fox and we got next week.
Got a bunch of funny people too.
I just don't know when we're going
to fit them in. We'll figure it out.
You got to kind of San Diego?
I believe so,
but I can't commit to it until
tomorrow. Mitt to meet Ya. That's next.
That's next Wednesday.
The 12th at the American comedy company.
You fuck heads. All right. Get a chance.
Get it take. I most likely will be there,
but uh,
I have a lot of shit I'm doing right now.
I'm in the middle of a lot of things.
I've got things moving.
I got higher primate, hard slash primate
or higher dash. Don't go to hire. Slash.
Prime. It's not me. Just shut
this fucking thing off. Jesus.
The show's over. We love
you guys, so thank you.
All right.